I wanted it so bad and he did it and as
the late and great Biggie Smalls once
said whether the game shakes me or
breaks me I just hope it makes me a
better man I know being next to you
Robert always makes me a better
commentator I'm excited to see you
despite no-shave November that you're
rocking how excited are you for MDL so
well I'm super excited that Maxime and I
you know we're on the same wavelength
here both got the beards glasses and
baby blue sweaters going but I honestly
am so stoked for this matchup because I
think it's going to be one the most
hotly contested one that people
definitely had problems predicting and I
think between the two of us Danni we're
not even sure who we find to be the
favor in this matchup
no you really do it and again obviously
we know all these guys who play in the
SEC pretty well but these two guys are
about as big as sweethearts as a guess
right I mean Maxime and Wesley it's it's
hard not to root for either of these
guys to move on and so ultimately we got
to do the right thing and root for
whoever plays better chess to move into
the semi-finals and we'll find out who's
gonna do so let's uh let's do what we
normally do here and run through the
format remind people of what is in store
here for Maxime voce the Grove and
Wesley cells the 2019 speed chess
championship is the same dog-and-pony
dance you've been watching for years you
love it we love it it's 90 minutes of
5-1 60 minutes of 3-1 and then 30
minutes of bullet it's a single
elimination bracket and of course the
winner not only moves on to the next
round but often takes home a lot of cash
in the process now you already mentioned
the predictions Robert and I think that
the I think that the predictions do have
a lot of people split so we're gonna
move right into that and break down what
people see here now I've noticed
something about the graphic we're gonna
show people here it says the smarter s
prediction so did you adjust this
yourself or is that is that something
that we're now being trolled with live
I've done nothing but I think we're
being troll
the amazing smarter chess because I
don't know if I would have predicted
Wesley so as a 63% favorite but I think
it actually makes some sense and you you
must be looking at me daddy wait maxime
an underdog and the speech has
championship not playing hey Karan
Nakamura now play magnus carlsen well
the key to this matchup honestly is that
Wesley so has been the best performer
and if you take an average of the five
plus one and three plus one blitz
segments Wesley says been the best
performer throughout splashes champion
history and he's only lost his matchups
last year in the finals to hikari
Nakamura and he was tied after all the
Blitz games were said and done and he
lost to Magnus Carlsen that was a
lopsided affair but that was the only
two defeats he has suffered in the SEC
no it's a great point and previously to
that his his loss was to Magnus Carlsen
right so while Wesley maybe doesn't pop
into people's brains when they think of
hey rank ranked the top three or five
best best blitz and bullet players on
chest comm or rank the top performers in
speech has championship history the
truth is he is right up there and and we
spent some time talking with Matt Jensen
who does a great job with the smarter
chess predictions as much as we have fun
pointing out what he's wrong but you're
right and he said that Wesley has really
been one of the most consistent
performers he is coming off a huge win
in Oslo Norway the official random a
world chess champion is who you're
looking at there on the right side of
your screen and so I I do disagree with
the prediction I actually think that
Maxime is is significantly better in the
bullet portion and to me if this match
is within a game or two before they head
into that fastest segment I do expect
Maxime to be the favorite but okay
that's why it's a coin flip that's why
so many people don't know who's gonna
move into that spot and face off against
vladislav our tinium in the semi-finals
and it's why we already have almost
4,000 of you with us across multiple
platforms wherever you're tuning in from
so a lot of people I think anticipating
this as one of the most exciting
matchups we're not allowed to say which
website actually has a line on
predicting SCC matches a lot of these
big events we hold actually have chest
lines that now we think of Vegas when
you think of that but you can tell
there's a split because that that
website actually also see
maxime is the favorite despite us seeing
Wesley so is the favorite so it's a coin
flip for a reason can't wait to see what
happens today
and I also can't wait to see what people
have to say about our daily question
Robert because at the end of the day
yesterday we had an interview with
Dingley Wren and he you know he made it
clear that he was tired and he was
playing late now one of the things
that's so great about technology is it
allows us to do the speech as
championship match we're bringing people
you know a direct webcam view to Dingley
Rennes number two player in the world in
a way that you don't even get to see him
when he's playing over the board right
but at the same time we're working with
these guys schedules and and you're
trying to get people in from all
different time zones whatever and so you
know we also see so many night owls guys
like Robert Hess after you know
basically getting into like fights in
the streets of New York cop in and play
blitz at 3:00 a.m. on their phone right
I mean Robert I mean I can't wait to see
what people think of this weather where
they're playing at a different time can
really affect your play or ultimately
you know if you're playing well or not
probably doesn't really have that much
of an effect about the time zone but
anyway can't wait to see what the play
is thinking I'm curious what you think
Robert as we as we get set to start here
in a moment I was going to make a joke
at your expense
about how it didn't matter what time of
day you played because Maxine but Sheila
Groff is going to adopt you so if I was
going to be mean I would have said that
in sincere fashion but that's not me I
respect like a good New Yorker you just
have the best way to just make me feel
you know at home I hope I'm in the city
that never sleeps so why is should time
of day affect my match you know why
should thank my skills let us know in
chat we know so many of you are already
active shout out to speedy cyclone FM
elipse almighty warrior premium members
in chess TV chat we've got so many of
you we got chess babe we got chess we we
got Tayyab nine-nine we got people all
across the globe watching this and
chatting so let us know your opinion
please with the hashtag speed chess on
Twitter and you might you know if you're
really impress us you might get a
diamond membership but if not you'll
probably have your Twitter account at
least shown on the show so all right
well we are moments away as we said we
have both players here it may be an
interesting thing that we come back to
we know that Wesley so arrived in
Kolkata
not yesterday I think the day before so
he may have a little bit of jet lag but
overall he is about to play in the final
rapid and blitz leg of the 2019
Grantchester right so he's done in his
normal time zone Maxine is in his normal
time zone but he's also wearing a blue
sweatshirt and that matches you and so
that clearly comes with a lot of bad
juju
a lot of bad vibes so who knows what the
better of it today why Danny um you know
a little bit offended that you would go
out of your way to talk about my sweater
negatively but if we talk about the
chest for a second you didn't mention
that West days about to play in the
final leg of the grand chest or that
means he's probably been preparing
because he was just in the Super bet and
now he's planning in India so he
probably studying openings very
thoroughly and I'm sure see how this
will pan out and this match both players
very well prepared I'm stylistically I
think they're a very interesting matchup
because Wesley so is very technical
player he's very sound he's very precise
Maxine likes to mix things up a little
bit more because he is the renowned
night--or player that you know we've
seen over the last bunch of years yeah
sometimes they get into trouble
sometimes he wins nice games in that
line and here we have an open Spanish
right you see that the pawn has been
captured on d5 which opens the roof
anyone the attacking on e5 but note that
Maxime is not just gobbling that pawn I
know many people say wait a second I
Scout two attackers and now 0-0
defenders before there was one but the
points of black gets ample compensation
if you're going ahead and just snatch
that pawn because of the open board and
the very nicely placed Bishop on b7 in
particular well in you highlighted
whether opening prep is gonna be a major
storyline here I predicted that Yan upon
yashi yesterday would really try to get
the best out of the first stage
especially because he feels he was the
faster player if he if he was confident
and comfortable as he said even even
better than getting a good position or
you know less important than that you
can't always rely on how preparing your
opponent and getting an advantage but if
you're confident and you're comfortable
that's gonna lead to good things when it
comes to rapid and blitz chess so I'm
with you on both these guys really
challenging each other in theory we know
how seriously they take these events and
I think we might learn something today
the games have begun reminder buddy you
can go to over to chess comm slash live
and follow the games directly
if you if you're into that and you can
stick right here with me and Robert no
matter where you're tuning in from
thanks for making chess TV part of your
day all right so what do we got here
Robert the well we got a position where
white is up upon and if I'm being honest
this or throws me back to a painful
memory where I was in the u.s. Olympia
team with Alexander ownership and he had
the black piece against Sergei karyakin
and it wasn't this exact position but a
similar position
well you sacrifice a pawn for the
potential of this white square diagonal
but mainly the two bishops and white has
not fully developed yet look at the
White Queen side of this one c1 the rook
on a one you don't really love having an
item b3 either but black has to prove
that the conversation is not just that
what we call compensations vague term
that we use but actually become
something concrete so how do we make it
concrete we play moves like Bishop h4
and Prohibition 1 g3 start getting a bit
of an attack over there on the Kings
side we may start with my crook ad e8
saying once I move this bishop away from
the e7 square now you're known e5 is
under attack and he plays Bishop d6 are
similar conceptually to Bishop h4
because you played Bishop g3 now but
perhaps the bishop is sitting pretty on
d6 and doesn't need to move there just
yet and a move like we're 88 start with
is a preferable watch I don't know why I
just like these positions more black
more for black long-term than than you
do I guess I'm supporting blacks because
you were saying I was reading your tone
as black really has something to prove
here in the compensation but the more I
look at it you love the bishop here I
don't know you're sort of reading
correctly into my tone what I would say
is that I like blacks chances but if you
don't do something concrete it's one
those positions where you end up just
down upon actually I think they're like
what did I go to 96 check here oh that
actually looks really nice in fact it
might you'd love to meet 96 check with a
move like King h8 but then just night of
five I think guards guards everything
and forks the Queen and Bishop so why
didn't he go for that well he can go for
it now yeah so he's fortunate that it's
not too late to do it the second time
that is checked the whole point
everybody is at pawn takes real chief
for check King moves and then okay rook
takes g3 you've won
back your piece and probably gain some
interest along the way with the dark
squares being completely blown open in
fact I think he's going to play because
the rook has no moves right now saying
you don't really want to play Bishop
takes b4 as my playing Bishop before not
oh and he does it okay he's found many
six check but he took them before first
I thought keeping the bishops made more
sense this looks perfectly good to me as
well because you can't stop a knight of
five unless you take my knight and as
you point out what you four picks up
that bish one g3 and Wesley shook his
head so I don't yeah I don't think he
saw that coming based on his reaction
there so the King moves and we get
Knight to f5 the problem for black is
there's really no there's no tricks here
there's no way to avoid just the trade
of the dark square bishop for the knight
which greatly favors white your white is
already up a pawn as you've been
highlighting and I guess that's you know
so even though we both like black and
then I misunderstood your tone and now
we both like white we're on the same
page that's a good sign but I will say
the reason why I spotted that tactic so
quickly I think it's very important to
explain what people might not see a
tactic or why you do in fact see
detected the reason I saw it so quickly
is I had a lesson late last night with
my student and I was saying whenever
there's a king in another piece on the
same file you always have to think about
if a rook and Lynn on that Square and
that sounds yep you know of course of
course Robert I want to think about
checking your King but I was just going
over a position that wasn't quite like
this but has similar themes and
something okay how do I get rid of the
Jeep on and put my rook on the same line
there goes my h6 check yep so I think
just training yourself to think about
these things in broader terms can help
you find them in a practical game
situation no it really it and we touch
on that a lot because we're both kind of
chess teachers and coaches at heart and
I think I think people asked well how do
you spot those tactics well a lot of
times it is just building the alarm I
always called it the alarm clock
building the muscle of when you see a
piece that's on the same line as a king
or when you see a queen and a piece on
the same diagonal or a file you have to
just it doesn't mean you always have the
license to kill and always become
obsessed with sacrifices but if you
don't consider the potential
consequences of pieces like that being
on the same line then you will miss
tactics so I think that's a great
and we see now Maxime has given back the
pawn but at the cost of I mean if you
look at sales position these double
pawns doubled pawns the F pawn is weak
I think he's hanging the Queen needs to
stay on the dark diagonal the long
diagonal otherwise i checkmated so Queen
takes before is probably a pawn you can
just scoop up and say well thanks for
the material I'll go up on once more yep
okay so he's taking his time here but he
earned it right he was up almost a
minute on the clock here
at one point and now he's still up 30
seconds yep
and trade my guess is you might even
just take a 8 and just Queen takes b4
and get greedy up in this like why not
just win your pawn back and keep the
party going I think somebody's going to
do and for Wesley you know day we'd like
to talk about this Ally and you're very
good at analyzing the psychological
perspective of the players and if you're
Wesley you just take time here and you
know you're going to lose this game most
likely just take a breath it's the first
game of the match you had a solid enough
opening you just missed Knight h6 just
didn't even come on your radar right so
you just like take your time hear it
lose the game eventually but get it
behind you just a right take a few
breaths and then start a new you know I
think I think either way we we always
talk about that there are some nerves
and you know we've even seen the best
players in the world do that where they
play out the game much farther than they
would over the board right there kind of
working out the kinks working out the
nerves and just you know making sure
that they feel good about their Mouse
making sure that they they feel good
about just you know where they're where
they're at where they're sitting I mean
all those things will make a huge
difference over a several hour 30 game
plus match online so our a5 is an
interesting move here by so he's doing
everything he can to mix it up he's down
a pawn and wow this move Queen d7 is
interesting because he's saying if you
play a four I can just take b7 and then
you're a pawn is actually pinned to a
ape he's also just preparing to bring
the other rook over to e1 this looks it
looks very good for Maxime
in fact the other threat on a4 is a move
just like d4 cutting off the Queen from
the diagonal so that things like Queen
f6 are you know default right now you're
right the propriety this act he goes for
it and now the threat of Queen f6 is
just too much here for Wesley so he
resigns throws in the towel and we
already have a an impressive victory out
of the gate here for Maxine Vashti the
Grove now again Wesley so is supposed to
be the favorite in the Blitz time
control so my my prediction generally is
if Maxime can keep this close the bullet
is where he can pull away yeah so a good
start for the Frenchman although I you
know I'm with you I think we both agree
that Wesley is the pre-match favorite in
the longer time controller because of
its history in the sec and actually once
he seemed to get stronger with every
single match experience he's gained so
the more matches he plays the stronger
he is in this format that said well I'll
give Wesley credit because against young
Christophe Duda he actually crushed Duda
in the Bullitt segment last year when
Duda was the bullet specialist he'd beat
a circuit Kraken and Alexander Chris
chuckle largely thanks to his prowess in
the speediest time control so I'm not
counting what see out until it's really
over you know we we always have this
debate between the two of us of how many
points behind our head muscle player be
heading into the last segment I think
this one really is anyone's chance as
long as they're within two three games
and again I didn't predict that Wesley
so would be the favor necessarily
against Magnus Carlsen in the world
Fisher random Chess Championship right
but you called me out on that and he
ended up being being quite quite the
player so I think I think sometimes you
just you know you see these guys throw
down and these in these formats and they
surprise you every time one thing that
doesn't surprise is usually they're
playing a very high quality brand of
chess despite despite the fast time
control so here we have a special knock
off I'm gonna take some notes here
because I I was engaged in some session
of cops recently and I don't think I
played very well as white they are very
tricky right because you have this
scenario where black has the two bishops
yeah but particularly this dark square
Bishop doesn't have a
to really do it's just sitting on g5 for
now not attacking anything you have this
weakness on d6 at any moment white might
put move a 2 to a 4 to break open the
queenside and challenge that pawn
structure so you have a potential target
on a6 as well and in general you mean
you can hear the way I'm talking about
it I've always found these positions to
be slightly better for white I prefer to
put the white side of these but Denny
you might have experience with the black
side no I actually don't and I am it's
one of the only Sicilians I've never
ventured to play regularly as black
positionally I also feel the same way I
mean okay we understand the concepts
that black wants well things like Knight
g6 eventually you'd like to maybe even
play f5 Black's goals are to try to
undermine the grip that white has on the
light squares in the center and
hopefully use the pieces that are on the
Kings side to launch some sort of attack
but you see Wesley playing very
technical here again he's maintaining
the grip on the light squares but at the
same time making it difficult for black
to do what you would normally want to do
in this pawn structure you want to get
things like f5 and f4 and create space
on the Kings side so Wesley I think has
a good position here much better than
his uh his first his first go of it yep
and Daniel add that you know we talk
about the d5 square often in these
Sicilians yeah but the square we and I
was about to say 93 looked pretty good
because another squids essential is the
c-4 square because right now black has
no pieces to cover the white squares you
have this night on e 7 now that covers
d5 but now that your opponent b5 is
under attack and he pushed before here
comes Knight c4 and not only just down
goes d6 but let's say I'm not even going
to capture that pawn I'm attacking it
making you put all your energy and
resources to defend it you can't go d5
if I cook on d1 you know that's always
the downside of these positions for from
blacks perspective and I think that
right now Wesley is dominating this
match yeah I agree and usually usually
in these special cops early
breakthroughs on the kingside with f5
are better right this structure is
positionally always dubious for black
the the light squares and the positional
consequences on the D file the weak pawn
as we've been highlighting but if it can
come with counter play if you can get g6
and f5 and start to get space
that's really what the special coffee
structure is all about so this is one of
those kind of bad signs for black I
don't
we'd have to back up and look at the
theory and I'll even scroll through it
because I'm curious here we have the
analysis board on the right where
exactly it went wrong for black and okay
this was a very mainline than 95 lines
so this is all theory here I think
already early right here after after
after the 97 line is played I know
there's variations where black can start
playing for g6 and f5 early the problem
is this move Knight cb4 by so I moved 16
Robert was really strong cuz you were
threatening 97 and knight c6 which is a
fork of the Queen and rook and that kind
of already tells me I don't know I feel
like white white got some better version
of their prep here because this is just
looking I mean just fantastic whites up
a pawn here in this endgame and playing
with house money already well speaking
of prep and kind of weird don't you
think is a little weird that Mexican
didn't play the night off and you play
the special golf we didn't talk about it
because we're so used to seeing so many
different openings right but we did
mention the maxime is a Niner specialist
and here he chose a specially called so
do you think he's concerned about what
Wesley might have prepared for him he's
just trying to be adventurous because we
saw him play a Cara Nakamura and they
played that Berlin a million times yes
and here on the first game he's
surprising us with his opening so what
do you make of that you know Maxime very
well hi I honestly didn't even think
about that I mean we highlight so much
he is the knight or specialist that that
strikes fear into the heart of his peers
but um you know III think let's we'll
have to wait and see I'm curious if this
is maybe a potential new new opening
Maxime is working into his repertoire
cos okay one of the great things about
the knight office he knows it really
well what's the bad thing about playing
it all the time everyone is preparing
for one particular thing right and when
you give guys who are also let's say
specialists on the white side of it guys
like Fabiano car wanting in the English
attack we've seen times where you know
it can still be a dicey opening to play
if you're going up against very very
deep prep and here Wesley just blew
Maxime off the board by the way I mean
let me show why the resignation happened
there because the we started going off
on a different kind of storyline but
Maxime by the way finally
guess we'll call it the sveshnikov f5
this move is about 20 moves too late in
this position and after takes at Knight
to c6 dual threats of 97 fork town
population king and rook combined with
just rushing the a pawn and he just he
had had enough so I think the question
Robert as we come back to the live game
here is whether we'll see this again
right I mean I I will we see Maxime
venture to this faction of copper than
once great question after that first
foray I I don't know if he really wants
to that was not a good showing by on his
part but okay you're entitled to a
single bad game but this particular game
right now we're when Game three now
aside one to one was they should have
more confidence he's playing the black
side of a position that I always think
is very solid because with d5 that's
where all of the tension is whether
white will take on d5
in which case black would prefer to take
with the knight and hand white nice laid
upon but if you take with a knight
you're removing one of your principles
King side defensive pieces right that
nine f6 covers aged seven so it also you
know just keeps whites Queen eventually
can come into a scores like Age 5 so
instead less he adopts this setup but
the downside this is the dark squares
over there on the Kings side of course
the bishop on b2 would love to be over
on aged six or something like this but
Queen d2 is still an option gentlemen
the Queen over the king side and you can
take on d5 at any moment as well just
keep them the back your head yeah I also
feel like the position is very solid and
the tension that surrounds the d5 c4
breakthrough for both sides is really
key and what I like about the way they
put these players high-level players in
chess approach how they approach these
positions is that they're very good at
maneuvering their pieces not just for
the current structure but always
anticipating what could happen if it
changes here I like g6 and Bishop f8 for
black because he's putting himself in a
spot where should he eventually take or
now take with the night and and create
the isolated pawn on d4 the bishop is in
an ideal spot not just on g7 but also
this pawn structure is very solid from
the threats you highlighted earlier
often in an i QP
White has tactics on the on the the b1
h7 diagonal so look at how black
basically Riemann
his pieces over the last several moves
to be in an ideal spot to now kind of
put pressure against the d4 pawn that's
just great technical kind of footwork if
you will by Wesley so right yeah and now
there's more tension it's maybe not pawn
tension but there's night tension look
at the 95-96
and black takes on e5 I take with the D
pawn I gain more space I can control the
g6 square the f6 square and if you don't
take on e5 which you probably shouldn't
the question is what do you do instead
it's a very essential question and what
move kids do we have well sometimes I'm
not suggesting it here cuz I don't like
it black plays oh well okay I was gonna
say f5 he goes for it I don't like the
move he like to move but f5 is the clear
drawback of giving you a backwards pawn
on the ephah so yeah once I move my
knight to d2 you know eventually your
Pony six is just stuck in this place
well I was gonna say I think one of the
key reasons why he justifies it is I
think he can get ok maybe not right away
but okay normally f5 would be even even
worse if somehow I was getting access to
the g5 square right away at this Bishop
4 on a different diagonal if Knight g5
was coming because combine that with
things like Bishop to c4 and you've got
real problems but I guess the point is
dynamically black is trying to say I
know this has really really big
potential drawbacks but I'm hopeful that
White's pieces not being on their normal
most active positions maybe the bishops
on f1 that can justify that I don't know
I mean I'm I'm kind of speculating here
but I start to look at Queen g5 and I
don't know why I guess I did I had this
like bias in me that's clearly coming
out of them in the way I'm talking about
where I just feel like black is is in a
good spot here to maybe turn things
around quickly
yeah the net-net 4 is particularly nasty
because 1983 check maybe not now but at
some point is looking pretty good
actually 90 ch3 check was it possibility
there but it probably forced to draw
yeah this is why Wesley's playing on
because he wants the D pod here you
actually write the position in just two
quick moves is good for ya and I think
Wesley just understood too that White's
normally with the drawback of f5 that
would be like White's pieces were not in
an ideal spot to take advantage of it
and now and now the D pawn is gonna fall
yeah
I sure why that's not possible because
after Bishop takes e5 which is a movie
typically do not want to play any of
your feet head of Bishop rook takes d5
there's Queen 65 and the Queen on d1 is
hanging at the end of that variation I
completed your sandwich there buddy
I showed Lincoln I showed it on the
board as you talked about it I
appreciate that because I you saw me
complete my sandwich before the show
that's right it's only Robert threw down
I mean I did with the veggie sandwich
was great
whoa all right well if you're just
getting here we have roughly 5,000 of
you across different platforms just in
English remember you can also watch this
in many different languages including
French Russian and Portuguese today Oh
in Spanish but thanks for being here the
2019 speeches championship now I stat
earlier Robert showed that Wesley so has
only ever lost the first game in a match
once twitch was to Magnus Carlsen he
lost the first game but then he he
bounced back right away and if he if he
does well here is black it looks like he
continues to do what we think what we
predict is going to be the storyline
that Wesley should have the edge here on
the slower time controls yeah and what
he is going to bounce back in this game
he's simply up a pawn in this end game
and well it's one of these questions
danny is the one pawn enough and at
first glance doesn't to me doesn't look
like it it's closer to level territory
it's a victory territory just because
white has control of the open sea file
which gives counter play if this rook
lands in seven the extra pawn is this
pawn on e6 not that easy to get that
pawn rolling and well now Knight c4 yes
almost an offer there because I think
he'll go back and we might get a repeat
nineties b6 just wins
it's a funny line though right because
if you go for that and then suddenly
blacks rook infiltrates you might have
rook and Knight working well on the
Kings side here and then but then white
gets king of two quickly so I'm I'm not
buying it I feel like I feel like Maxime
has defended this very well and look at
the clock by the way yeah good for
Maxine he was up two minutes earlier but
he's been a long time trying to figure
it out and now a four at some moment oh
I just have an outside past pawn an
advantage here yeah if you play a four
and
and become sort of a split board as we
say with counterplay on both sides the
bishop should be the better minor piece
sort of exchange there but you know the
one the one counterpoint to that is
right now black is clearly the one with
frets right here comes f4 there's also a
five the rook is infiltrating to the
second ring so these are very
double-edged positions for a reason and
then the rook and Knight will work well
in close proximity everyone so you want
them next to each other operating
whereas the rook and Bishop are a long
distance relationship that Robert has
his envious of so well he's giving up
the g3 pawn look at Maxie goes running
in but here comes Knight take chief
remix but East six is hanging b5 is
hangs and Bishop takes b5 followed up
route 66 and I guess I'm just a fan meet
g4 here see ya you said Knight 6 g
three's a thread so she goes G 4 I like
it I want two things I want F 4 and the
knight to come to g3 but just to show
everybody wait actually it almost does
work cuz the bishop would be hanging so
well can I get F 4 I have to go king d4
I guess right and then I'll get Knight G
so now I actually got what I wanted
which was to keep this because with
night of - where are you putting the
bishop you should take be fine I guess
yeah I guess I guess I thought it was
getting more okay no not happening look
he's already transposed into kind of the
idea I want which is f4 but now he's
done it better because he's taken away
the d4 square for the King so yeah mr.
Oaks f4 check in some moment could be
annoying not to mention if the bishop
leaves the diagonal brookie to check at
the right moment so black is just trying
to rely on the pi/3 that aren't too many
pawns remaining so that night might have
to sacrifice itself from the b-pawn yeah
it's a moment perhaps there's
potentially and any you know I'm gonna
say look at the H 8 squared up we're
gonna color the bishop wrong color
so if Brooks get traded and the knight
can sacrifice up for the b-pawn after
honest traded for those F any pawns then
it's already a draw because the bishop
does not match the h8 square and well
maxime going for the pawns right away
returning rookie three such an easy move
to forget about because the bishop was
on be fighting it's a psychological
thing right we're just not considering
moves like this but they're they're
calculations so impressive and now look
at the clock completely turned around
Wesley is up on time
he can play rookie three check the
question always is rookie three check
King C for you helping my king I think
he wants something with E for where he
can sack and rush the F on I think I
think he's he's gonna bore through so
you have to keep super late for yeah
you're right just get rid of the F three
pawns that you're at Ponca star yeah
here he goes efore I think you want to
take with the bishop to force the rook
ending Oh totally wrong he goes for this
what does maxime see here I think that
was very dangerous decision because you
can't play Brooke f5 96 check so he did
he just miss that I mean never know but
now there's 92 isn't there 92 King d4 93
okay black has a draw if he wants it
webinar King defy view block the F oh no
I can't do both okay here's the line I
thought I could push F and trade at the
same time while the bishop is blocked
but I can't and if I trade he takes and
the bishop guards f3 so probably maxime
has already calculated all this the
essential question I was wondering who
was playing for win and and I don't know
me now we're gonna see the players shake
hands soon because yeah but you have to
give up your be pawn in the process so I
think just you know you can take on e4
with either pb5 catch me off I think
Maxime is saying I think I'm the one
playing for a win now he's gonna take
the night with the king keep the rook
and I think now Wesley needs to come
behind the pawn this is rook ending
lessons here everyone you don't want
your rook stuck in front of a pawn in
prison so I think Wesley will recognize
he's the one playing for a draw and play
Brooke c1 rook v1 I think I'm playing
route c5 here and they're all five dude
that was sick I'd show it let me show it
Robert you're so sneaky
alright let me show rooks e5 if you
trade everything the F pawn runs
what a move they agreed on a draw
immediately yeah rook c5 and so it just
forces everything off the board and both
sides are gonna get Queens or as what
happened in the game we're just gonna
get a rook ending and it's just an
immediate draw so wow what a fancy what
a fancy finish yeah fancy finish your
nickname in high school right no but we
can pretend like it was okay and
honestly that was a very topsy-turvy
game began at first we liked Wesley's
position with black you want a pawn then
it seemed like he stumbled immediately
after winning set on and then maxime had
a look like a better position and
somehow the knight and Brooke combined
yeah be very tricky and not allow him to
it's even more an advantage so I think
both players can be disappointed by
splitting that point but ultimately we
saw the tide match right and we're in
another Sicilian to Simon Idol shout out
to platinum member Psalms Ted in the
chest TV chat who says thanks for the
great commentary Danny and Robert
watching this with my fifth-grade class
right now hey class and Grand Master
someday so thank you for your support
their homestead and in hate class thanks
for being here watching chefs TV all
right yeah so Bishop c4 typical right
Paul went to f5 attacking the bishop in
fact trapping the bishop if not for the
square yep somehow this looks not very
good for black I mean I I'm I have to
admit that when I see 87 positions
especially with the open dark squares on
the Kings side if that palm was on g7
rather than g6 I might say okay black
it's probably still right a bit worse
but not going to get checkmated at some
point soon here I just the class just
went nuts so shout out to the class okay
here's where I'll take black side now
because before it was a special coffin I
couldn't defend Maxine but I do play the
night orphan I think these positions are
much more dynamic than than that and the
main point is that black may never get
castled and the tension on f5 combined
with the G file becoming open what black
really wants to do in these positions
and that's what b5 does is to start
putting pressure on e4 okay a4 is a
great
because the moment you make this a
two-board scenario meaning uh let's say
open lines on both sides of the board
then black has to do something with the
King now they have to get castled before
things like a B a B and rook
infiltrations start happening yeah so
but okay just to point out if black
could just take the Queen right now and
instead of that movement but I could
have just put it on b7 this would prove
my point where I'm defending b5 hitting
e4 guarding a8 and that's the kind of
stuff that you're hoping to get in these
Knight orbs and Maxime is is a little
bit worse here I do agree but but I
don't know I guess I'm you know these
dark squares are a little overrated it's
not quite a dragon for white yeah I just
think that black is slow as you said the
Queen was unbeatable queen b7 wouldn't
help here because rook a 7 is the movie
I want to play regardless and I'm just
first to the punch
it's yeah with you sorry good no I
played the night or if I also play the
white side of it so this isn't about us
Robert this day is not about us it's
definitely about us it's never been
about us and never will be about us but
I am about what white is doing on the
Queen side over here because just seems
like black is going to lose at least one
pawn in the process these Knights
these are happy nights in the
fifth-ranked on a5 on b5 jumping into
the action night a7 is an idea for white
so you can get a knight to c6 all seems
very happy in White's position here
agreed agreed
take stands now the big issue here for
white is you want to be able to kind of
consolidate everything and not lose e4
but I think you can do that even like
Knight c4 I like 94 I was born he just
played it in fact ink on d3 attic with
the pawn and I'm never getting in my
punch yup
and now e5 the problem so again Wesley
today saying I did prepare Robert was
right I am getting ready for the grand
Chester wrap in a blitz which we'll be
covering right here on chess TV if you
want to mark your calendars that starts
mañana I think I'll just making sure
you're still speaking Spanish over there
buddy that was all but yeah there we go
we got our schedule up the Tata Steel
India rapid and blitz
Magnus Carlsen Hikaru Nakamura Wesley so
need i say more
follow chess TV no matter where you're
tuning in from get alerts when we go
live and see our coverage Robin and I
will not be doing coverage of that it's
a little it's a weird time in India for
us but we Robert and I will be covering
the grand chest or final from London and
then of course the speech has
championship returns on December 4th
with Nakamura versus Duda so busy busy
day busy times yep and well what's he so
needs a good showing there so he can
obviously compete so he can finish in
the top four yeah of the GC so he still
has a chance to qualify for the finals
he does yeah all right he's out he's out
of events so he's hoping that the other
players around his score group do not do
too well in India right okay Brooke d4
Maxime is trying to get counter play
he's trading trading pawns for pawns
this is one of those ways you try to
draw where you just hope that you can
somehow win C 2 and E 4 before white
wins all the rest of your pawns whoa an
exchange sac give me that piece he said
I thought he was gonna take d4 but whoa
now he's just like a 5/5 Knight C to d5
isn't white just winning a piece
yeah Knight c95 yep so that was well he
started down a pawn and then he got
desperate and now he's not a beast
Tobias knows in the chess TV chat asks
do we think Wesley so we'll have a boost
of confidence in his chess career now
that he won a match against Magnus
Carlsen obviously talking about the
world fish and random Chess Championship
Robert that's not our daily question but
it is the Daily Double from Dan think
about that and give us an answer it a
little bit let's tease him don't give it
yet I was not saying what is the Daily
Double
all right well let's see how he finishes
the game off because this is one of
those position oh okay
so he decides to give up one of his
knights or both of them to get the rook
that was saying now he has rook e1 I
think okay Brooke d1 also works but he
could have traded the rooks
he had enough time to do it before the
depo would run but is this the best
exchange to be up because you're gonna
have to on 2 on the kingside granted
black spawns are split over there is it
the easiest position to win especially
if you know Erica traded I think so
because it you know it eliminated the
complications let's back up to the
position where that actually happened
because you're kind of referring this
position after rookie to you could have
played something like rook f3 right but
then rogue d2 d2 comes and it feels I
don't know it feels kind of hard for
white yeah maybe it's you're right I
mean it's not too clear cut but at the
same time this position there are plenty
of practical chances for black to hold
such an endgame yeah because it's not
that much material for what why didn't
he play my move rookie would my main
point is that things like okay take
stakes in d3 or too slow I pick up the
knight and get behind if I could get a
pair of rook south or maybe it doesn't
matter maybe it's still what you're
saying which is kind of like look black
wins the f6 pawn white wins the D pawn
and it's it's gonna be a hard exchange
to prove right yeah I mean honestly I'm
I don't think the chances are that great
here 93 for example right now I don't
even know what you do cuz you go rook f2
Emilia of rook e1 check can't you
tonight f1 check and all of a sudden
you're not getting out of my chest
hmm okay actually I already think that
black is not much worse that's a great
point I guess I'm kind of overestimating
feeling like Wesley was converting now
this will be interesting if maxime yet
again holds if you're one of the nearly
9,000 viewers we have across the world
right now I can tell you that Wesley so
probably was the one who should have won
last game - if we were choosing so what
does that do for the confidence right
for Maxime he's now held maybe a couple
games in a row yeah I mean I would say
the match so far has been about level in
terms of how they've played right Maxime
is struggling in the openings with black
that's clear yeah played the specialty
coffee got a terrible position
he put the night off in this game he had
terrible position and he's very
fortunate that he's in this position
which is still obviously better for
white and pretty decent winning chances
but he needs to work on something in
between these games to figure out what
he could play against Wesley they play
five in the first move and just play
solidly because it's not working out
from the Sicilian yeah yeah I agreed the
one win Wesley had was in a special akov
so Maxine was black and especially cough
Maxime won the first game of the match
which was an open space
yep here comes king of three unless the
deep on is too fast you gotta go to d3
okay but that means that you're not
really threatening to make any progress
here I think that Maxime is officially
held I mean the H pawn holds back the G
pawn right the knight is safely
protected on f5 by the King King e5 and
I think I think we have we will have
peace maybe there's some kind of suits
wrong opportunities I need to figure out
how to make it work but perhaps there's
a way that white can sort of winning a
crucial tempo at the right moment
because Knights are notoriously bad as
they cannot gain or lose tempo well
that's a weird move rook takes I feel
like he's gonna lose both H and D but
when G right so he's saying if okay
Brooke h4 Knight g2 rook d4 Knight f4
check we might have some sort of
Perpetual so sir can I throw in Rookie
for jockiboi
first but still King f5 I mean there
you're getting closer to this H pawn I'm
not sure how long it will be able to
stand the board
Wesley taking his time here I think he
feels confident he should be able to win
but this is getting a little bit a
little scary nights are tricky in these
situations you don't want to suffer to a
fork
there you go you win Rookie for Jay yes
I think you're right though King up five
and just followed up but then bringing
the knight back yep blacks chances
should be pretty nice in the whole tier
we've had several subscribers and
supporters here today thank you so much
for your for your donations and your
love we appreciate it you make these
events possible all right I think it
should still be a draw here at five yeah
cutting the rook off your thread your
knight g2 and that should be it yep
okay as long as you don't play King h5
first which would not be ideal haha well
maybe and maybe still holds in some line
so does I feel like when you point out
the most obvious blunders you're giving
advice directly to me
well here it works just go night no 1963
he's trying to trick him oh that would
be sick let's shield the subs wrong
analysis board 96 King III Knight h4
king of for zugzwang black has to move
away and lose the knight and that's why
he played like this and he brought the
king in first so now he can just
blockade them at night 85 next and then
you'll get your counter play with the F
hun
okay you're just gonna tickle this one
out here so the king is coming but the
night comes a trouble exactly and then
you can push the F pawn down the board
to help you hold yeah don't play King g4
Dan note to self don't just self don't
go alright draw what's he gonna play it
out I mean I guess he probably should
and again if you are nervous if you're
tired
this is Wesley's opportunity we see him
okay he takes the draw a little bit
frustrated again and I and I think I
think that was some honest kind of
dejection there cuz he did I know you
were saying it's been about level but
the last two games if we had to
summarise Wesley's been the one pushing
right so it starts to feel a little bit
like you're you know we don't like those
storylines and matches like this because
if the victories are escaping you you
can lose matches by not converting yep
and you know definitely hurting me run
yesterday right you've crazy the final
result was clearly heavily in yonder
publishers favor but Dingley run had
several advantages that he didn't
convert on and that's why the match
seemed to get out of hand
in the early go question there from
prof. gamer when is the hikaru due to
match it is December 4th thank you for
asking that mark your calendars that'll
be fun one as well because I obviously a
car being the favorite but young
Christopher dude up playing super elite
level chest these days in classical he
is nearly 27 60 his speed chess champion
history has been one marked by great
upset victories in his favor
they call him the comeback kid I think I
call me that and then say they so that
it sounds more legitimate but you also
called him Rick Astley jr. and yet try
to rickroll me in the process that's
right
all right let's talk about this exchange
here because this is educational I think
for the viewers to break down how can
white justify a departure of a fee and
kettle bishop denying the protection of
the light squares give us give us the
Grand Master one-two punch here why is
bishop takes c6 align I don't really
like the line the line is because what
black gains out of white giving up this
Fein candor Bishop is controlled the
light square right what white has yet to
Castle kingside
which means that squares h3g two are not
as vulnerable just yet right and the
long term potential that's what white is
counting on against these double pawns
now it's not easy to pile up pressure on
those pawns which is why I don't
particularly love it but you can unblock
spawns if you gain important space in
the process you see this often in
openings at the Rasul emo if you say a 3
B 4 at the right moment say okay I'll
under your seat pawns but you lack space
and your two bishops are not working in
open space they just you know happen to
be on the board because we've got kind
of a closed center so while normally yes
you look at this bishop you look at
these light squares and it spells
problems but but where's the beef right
so you put the bishop on e3 but okay
Maxime is gonna move the rook and then
how are you really following up on these
the weak squares right but okay I mean
but I'm with you because I'm gonna show
on the announcement why I agreed that
this line is kind of weird cuz even
though we're justifying the departure of
the bishop normally it's done like if
these pawns are isolated right like
remove the D pawn and look at how
horrible those pawns are they're weak
they're double they're isolated it's bad
but in a situation like this and even in
the live position while the pawns are
doubled now they're not really that weak
right so the fact that black has been
given the bishop pair of long term and
the weak light squares I don't know I'm
I'm with you as well I asked you to kind
of explain it but I don't know to me to
me this is a definitely a double edge
game for sure and I don't think it's the
worst version the worst version black
could happen this kind
exchange yeah especially because there
no weak pawns to attack so black says I
the two bishops I can start breaking
over the position with an eventual f5
move that surely will be played and
there it is here he comes now if you if
you played B takes e5 you just help
blackout but undone in the pond with D
takes d5 and return the rook on b8 is
perfectly situated there yep looks good
it looks really good for black yeah I'm
liking it more and more and at some
point this tension is going to break in
the closed position and these pieces
will come to life
right on cue they're a position
completely locked by pawns is what we
would define as a closed set up usually
you define a closed position by whether
the center itself is open or closed but
if the position stays closed the bishop
here won't be that big of a deal but if
it opens up this LightSquared bishop and
the bishop pair in general will be an
advantage for what yep definitely I mean
but this position isn't closed like the
one we saw in the diagram because there
are still pawn tension pawn breaks are
possible here it's not a totally locked
position as we saw instead we would call
that a semi closed position right Karpov
special and here we got the baseball
field right in the center right from
there yeah the dynasty 5d 45 and what
Roberts adding as far as the context of
that comment about it's it's a closed
position right now but it's considered
semi closed because there's enough
tension points where files and diagonals
can become open that it's not something
you would consider deadlock totally but
but that and that's really where the
storyline of the position is all about
who how do we break this right black
would love for white to make some move
like captures and start to open up light
squares and and here black decides to
capture maybe he'll take twice and
dd-does giving up a 4b but trying to
maybe use the B file in the process yep
black is first the activity because if
this e 1 rook was already on a1 you can
play rock a7 yep I might have a
different tune here but if you ever play
rook a 1 then this rook be too he's hung
his queen what is he doing wait oh he is
rookie 2 at the end wow I've looked at
the camera because normally I see some
emotion but Maxime just you know calm is
a kid over there
he knew his position was
which is why he went for this yeah but I
really like this decision look out look
how difficult it is now for black
oh wait d3 falls nevermind that horrible
bad Queen sac magazine no but you're not
totally wrong because he can't possibly
set up a blockade here it doesn't seem
likely but there is outside potential of
setting up a blockade in which case
decision yeah but c4 adjustable c4 is
falling and the deep I we're doing a
role reversal here usually you're the
one who sticks up for the Queen stabbed
bad sacrifices now I'm the one who's
trying but look what I've done to you
look what I've done to you you've
corrupted I've corrupted no this is this
is a bed this was you yet your instincts
were right first it was done out of
desperation let's back up and really
kind of show it because the truth is
back in this position I think as you
said you would normally like white if
White was already on the a file but he
wasn't and so black was the one ahead of
the game he didn't want to settle on a
passive move rook a to everybody to
guard rook b2 so instead he kind of
justifies in his brain a bad queen sac
something we hope he does tomorrow
versus me that being Maxine and and but
the fact that the D pawn falls in
exchange for you getting enough material
is just I didn't see that when I first
went for it if if something like this
happens just to show this is why I liked
it for a brief second cuz now you've got
a rook a knight and a pawn and dominance
on the blockade here
I would love white but the fact that the
D pawn falls is kind of a catalyst and
and that that is gonna be yeah Wesley's
Wesley's gonna go in to win this one and
take the leap and Maxime is just kind of
wasting time right now I'm not in the
unsportsmanlike way but he's gonna calm
himself we know Maxime is a player who
can go on till we've seen it happen
yep and I think it's very important for
Maxime to keep his nerves in check to
make sure that he's feeling like okay
every game is a fresh one every move is
an opportunity for me to improve on what
I've been doing yo just take a breath
take a breather yep and so how what was
what was the advice we were we were
given do see how quickly they just
played this yeah I guess we'll focus on
that but I think there's something to be
said for making
sure your last moment your last memory
of a game is not like the most negative
emotional one like take a breath
calm yourself trying to figure out why
you blunder maybe what the positive
takeaway is and then resign and move on
right I think there is something to be
said for that Robert especially in
matches like this where you don't have a
rest day to do it you got to do it now
in the middle of the show right and I
think that that's kind of what you were
touching on right yeah and he changed
this opening by taking on a five first
I'm liking the last game when he allowed
that tension to still show it real quick
cuz I was highlighting that
psychological point but yeah right here
is where the difference maker was
everyone instead of Bishop c4 which is
what we just saw in Game five if you're
keeping track closely
maxime took on at five and and by the
way I like this better because to me
this is the version I was trying to
explain when I was justifying black
position is that you don't you don't
want to Castle a lot of ways you want to
use the G file but you don't want it's
what happened in that last game you
don't want the b5 move to be a move you
can't take back and white makes it a to
a two-line scenario where both sides
become open so I think this is a better
version for Mac seemed that he had
earlier I agree and right now after
Queen d5 the c2 pawn can be captured and
so what is was he thinking by giving up
this pawn maybe he just wants like rook
C one after it
which is why Maxime keeps the position
closed a very interesting decision right
there then I think needs to needs
further analysis that well I don't know
but that's nice I like I like the
decision not to take it this is what
white wants in these knight or if you
want a two line sword right you want you
want open why can't I figure out the
right way to say that what is the right
way to say you want open lines on both
sides of the board there you go okay
wow that was hard you did it you want
lines on both sides of the board Queen
takes B sevens an issue so this is what
you want to avoid in any night or if
where your King has to be in the center
everybody you can get away with this as
long as it's not an a to open line
scenario and so that's exactly what
Wesley is trying to do is open up open
up variation open up lines on both sides
of the board yeah I'm gonna retire
I'm gonna retire if this met I can't
speak today buddy it's okay I'll forgive
you eventually
so here the detention d6 captures it
this ship f force looking at rook on g8
you were talking about this earlier is
the king gonna sit on d7 Danny I love it
I mean you might have to you might not
really have many choices here and the
great news of this run at four as
it covers the F file and covers the C 1
square because Brooke a 2 c1 would be a
very good move in most positions but you
can't do it without just give me a free
rope yep and also the time the time is
suggested to me that Maxime is back in
his comfort zone this is the kind of
night or if he needs to get today these
positions are ones that frankly he has
more experience than any any of his
peers any of the best players in the
world and it's not I'm not saying the
position is objectively good for I mean
it's a very unclear position um but it's
a position that he knows well and that
he can play and again that King on d7
this is this is a night or this is like
a walk in the park for a night or flare
no big deal
yep and he gave Mike Queen e6 if he
needs to to kick this Queen out of the
d5 square and it's very difficult for
white to kick this bishop off of f4 and
he does it by mystery there but not
Queenie six forces the Queen's off the
board seems because either you lose the
d6 pawn right away or you know you drag
queens and then take on that for a
knight secondi six and and probably
objectively we're headed for a draw but
still I would say that's a a good result
given how badly black's games have been
for maxime today right he's really
hasn't figured out his openings until
this one ya know this was by far his
best game with the black pieces that
felt double-edged both sides actually
chances whereas the other games he was
kind of getting positionally steamrolled
it seems like everything was going
Wesley's favor here only black can be
better in this endgame I think because
if you trade the Brooks you this eat
palm which is already directly Apache on
and that can be quite a nuisance
especially if your King gets cut off so
like if you play King g5 maybe in the
King Defour yeah what if I just get my
King yet okay he started a five which
also makes sense but I'm thinking that
black King starts venturing into enemy
territory not only is it helping the
past pawn yeah but it can also go over
to the Queen side to attack these two
white pawns over there as well no it's
fantastic
and yeah the past pawn will be the
difference-maker if somehow
maxime can get an edge something tells
me best play
again Brooke ending you know newsflash
best played maybe believe might be
leading to a draw but if Ricky seven
comes here get the okay he goes rook c7
which has ideas of check check and then
start gobbling but rookie seven just
getting the rook behind the pawn is
always something to keep an eye out in
these rook endings and the essential
question right now is if kg to brooks
each you check rook f2 is possible i
think it is in which case white will be
better in that king of pawning game
there's a difference between the rook
endgame in the pawn and game the reason
why i'm saying the Pawnee game would be
so good for white is you have the
outside pawns in this case the H and G
pawns but when King f3 first this is
just a very now it's getting very nice
if you buddy wants is g5 and the King
runs this way to help I think you want
snag d7 still do it he could take and
then play chief 5 if the checks the
checks whatever happened first are kind
of just based on their calculation that
they can do that Robert and I can't
right now because they're they're
engaged but but you really just want to
be okay now he didn't get it in time the
whole point of having g5 everybody was
so you could meet this check with King
to g4 now he has to go back to g2 if he
wants to hold h3 he's just going to
we're gonna we're gonna just Maxime okay
so now Maxime has the taste in his mouth
for the first time today of letting one
go that he feels like he could have won
right yeah I mean I'm not gonna speak in
such extreme sir I feel like one is a
little strong but I think he's
disappointed of like I could have played
and made my points like more difficult
they could have pressed him more and in
that case yes maybe if he pressed and
pressed press I could have won the game
but I don't think objectively there's
anything yeah overwhelmingly
advantageous for him okay yeah fair but
it was definitely his best night or best
game is black of the day right yeah and
then yeah and now we see a very quick
end game here which okay well with the
white pieces you'd hope to have a slight
edge your Bishop on g2 always better
than the opponent bishop on the white
squares because well you're gonna need
to protect your c6 pawn the mission when
g2
covers the scope of the diagonal you
might play Bishop e6 actually to put
your fish one d5 or 995 is a way to
close that diagonal but because Maxine's
moving so quickly I imagine he's very
familiar with we have eleven thousand of
you watching in English right now across
multiple platforms and many more
international I want to take this moment
just to remind everybody that right
after the SCC today is femme fatale
another team at chess battle we haven't
done one of those in a while
the last time team chefs happened Robert
Hess and I were on the losing side
versus the chess bras we don't want to
talk about it but we have a femme fatale
that is Europe versus North America
going down right after this so see those
ladies Maria Andrea Nova Otto Rudolph
Alexandra butch has and Jennifer a
hottie playing team chess right after
this should be exciting so yeah we got
he's got in that match by the way they
don't watch our show so you can be
totally honest I was about to say I'm
not even sure who the favorite is yeah I
think it's a very balanced match I think
I'm leaving team Europe okay you're
gonna say why Shana is potentially the
most active like of the four players I
feel like she might be the strongest
right now Jenna's Jenna's right there
with her so I think sometimes if you're
like looking at the matchup you could I
think on it might be the strongest
overall player right now of the four and
that kind of makes me lean their way
okay I think that Alexandra can make her
break it in the sense I mean that she
plays sometimes she does the boat is
gambit blenders are Queen but most of
times she's playing very well and she
has very active ideas which right and
when I say that you see some of these
even elite players where at any given
game you're like they're gonna win or
lose but you're not expect them to be
solid some like mom and Jar we often
expect them so I think that I probably
also lean towards Team Europe slightly
because of their bit more active it
feels like but something about Team
America I I agree and you know Alexander
bow chavs
and Eric Rosen teamed up at the the
twitch rivals event we had the comodo
boss rush and they way outperformed
their objective strength in in major
part because of their chemistry and I
think Alexandra is a fan
gnostic teammate she's very good and
with just knowing knowing the right way
to find good chemistry and I think that
that's I think that's a huge point in
their favor so good point
that'll it's it's it's gonna be a
toss-up so well you know it's not going
to be a toss-up this gamer this game
right here this looks fantastic for
Wesley and he might be about to take a
two-game lead file and I'm happy to see
you
this is was the worst way possible for
white to regain the pawn you have these
double D pawns and split Queen side
pawns and blacks rook is already kind of
in your face on the second right there's
what D - okay I'm 52 in double in the I
think he maybe still should but he's
kind of in control anyway you can play
Brooke eight to be seven he plays it
before I can highlight it and again
whites rooks are much more stuck than
blacks rook d1 here
rook do you want I have Brooke c2 I
think then I go rook a four it looks
very awkward but the very least I'm
stopping you from infiltrating to the
Batcave we go
let's analyze rook d1 he goes for it
rook c2 R okay for at some point okay
we're getting this exact line that's why
we're in the Batcave so maybe maybe I go
for rook b2 b2 and sacrifice a 7mm
but probably not right cuz yeah oh okay
I love this movie for because I was
gonna say one of the big problems with
this line Robert is if even even if you
take on e to I can kind of get out and
run into the light square so this movie
for does have my threat in mind what
you're doing is you're trapping the King
here so that now if you go for this
second rank it might come with a mating
net that King can't get out yeah that's
a fair point and that's why he played g4
right to cut this place c5 then I want
to take your F or pawn away and you know
after that my team go to f3 so I think
c5 here and I think c5 is key because if
you don't you're gonna see Brooke b2 b2
ins because the king is trapped but
alright you're right he finds c5 and
looks like maxime might be escaping by
the right now many hairs on his chinny
Chinchin
yeah he's copying me notion of November
yeah we uh we have a lot of similarities
just he's a much better chess player and
I see yonder paw mushy in the chat
saying it's a coin toss I think though
I'd say nvl is stronger in bullet so
that's a young DePalma shoes take
yeah and that's that's been kind of my
take to but I think right now obviously
Wesley up a game for a reason and this
is I got a feeling about today I know we
knew this was gonna be a good match but
something tells me I don't know you feel
it over time free chess I'm here for
free chess free cuz we just want to get
out of it's what we get out of you right
you've been doing these for free for
years gosh I know somebody called the
IRS anyway if I played yes I was
wondering if he was gonna take it and
you're trying to play his second rook to
the fourth rank he tried to take this
Jeep on but instead he plays f4 which to
me I feel you're not really threatening
much because if you take on e3 you oh
actually you are f6e through his pretty
F takes we take you win the rook yeah we
should show that
yeah let's shut F take c3 okay we'll
just make a random move if F takes c3
rook takes c3 this is the threat and
Bob's your uncle game over so okay so
Brooke d4 stops that but I do think
black is still in the driver's seat now
he can take and take d4 he's won a pawn
he has aged six here aged six probably
taking a five and then at least restore
material equality for the man
no you're right that means he has to
count over T five you know D was doing
he was double-checking the King upon
ending classic Wesley yeah what's he
something pawn here so yeah you can you
can give up h7 and try to run I think
seven really cuz otherwise it's a draw
oh wow he plays on well here's the C
pawn and White's King is sort of cut and
blast King can help the C pawn push so
don't be surprised if he just gives up
the age six bubbles c5 here says you
know go for that H bond have at it
yeah I'm gonna start pushing myseif on
the downside is y can go h4 h4 instead
of rookie six check okay maybe he's got
any weight anyway yeah wait but c3 now
what was he too fast that's too fast
Wesley's got that look like hey dude
yeah thank you miscalculated that like
he almost just looked at
across the camera by the way the players
can't see each other on camera if they
choose to do so because it's in a shared
and secured zoom call I know some of the
players we've talked with them like
keeping the camera up because they can't
see their opponents reaction
Wow Maxime may have just so let's
analyze let's back up real quick cuz I
think you you pointed out maybe there
was a better move order instead of
taking age six he needed to play age
four right away but still yeah well but
if you if your pawn trying so he played
each form right away seeking a tempo
there or is still c4 I think you still
see four because I can't even take back
on g5 and if rookie five King before
takes I still have c3 still very fast
yeah right right so maybe maybe this
idea that Wesley kind of peaked over at
Maxime he was kind of like I think I'm
winning here notice the notice the
bridge idea everybody that the point is
rook see a check is blocked by rook c7
and this pawn is is still too fast baby
girl on c1 perfectly placed rook because
it helps you stop a rook check from
behind the pawn and also when the rook
tries to get on the side of the pond
you've room d1 yes either you're going C
seven or I was just highlighting that
the third reason the rook is perfectly
placed it also was stopping any White
King run over just a show on the
analysis board so Robert highlighted the
rook was literally perfect helping with
the kind of lucena bridge idea where you
block checks ready to help the pawn
advance if it needs to come to d1 and
also preventing a king rush this whole
time to help so just fantastic and those
are the kind of victories when you talk
of Wesley so that you think he's going
to get its technical super precise and
he catches people making blunders and
those types of variations like that that
little peek over he added Maxime that
was classic so as a classic Wesley one a
little peek like hey I think I
calculated one move deeper in that line
than you buddy I think I got you well he
definitely has been getting Maxime the
early going here and Maxime once again
we have a different setup for him in
this game because he is precision on g7
Fein Kennedy it's from a night off but
it's looking dragonish and well Danny
what do you make of this your sis I'm
player do you like this setup for black
it's a dragon or first of all right
not to be confused with Gandalf or any
other elven but I don't know it's a drag
of Dorf Ganondorf but okay so the dragon
door if jokes aside is will analyze it
real quick is this combination of dragon
development along with the move a6 right
so you start with Knight or if you
switch to the dragon which is defined by
this fianchettoed Bishop on the dark
squares in a Sicilian what do I think
about it Robert honest truth I think it
sucks I don't think these lines are very
good for black and I think it's I played
the dragendorff Danny I drew got a calm
skin with it many moons ago you know but
you're really good ok will you try to
see my Maxime huh no okay come on no
these guys are great but objectively the
dragon Dorf is a reason why it's
featured as let's say surprise weapons
you're not making a regular habit of the
dragon Dorf in your repertoire Robert
despite your draw versus calm ski and I
need to tell you something can't tell
you something what Sam chenkin once told
me that he thought the dragendorff was
pretty good opening really yeah well if
Shanklin says it it must be true that's
what I was thinking told me that I was
like well Shanklin prep I trust it's
actually me jokes aside Sam is one of
the best prepared player Samm is Samm is
more prepared than his rating even
suggests and that's saying something cuz
he's a twenty seven twenty plus player
but Sam is okay alright maybe I'll give
it another look-see huh either but you
know just just noting that Sam said that
to me and I was like wow I can't believe
that somebody's company in the
dragendorff and it's not me being
facetious interesting well okay we ended
up kind of on a practical debate about
I'm sure for most the viewers they're
like what is this open what is even the
debate about the opening the basic point
is it's a very sharp opening what that
means is you know if you're not well
prepared theoretically you can get
shoved around and and and and and find
yourself regretting your opening choice
that's the kind of opening it is and
very dangerous but if you get positions
like this let's highlight the the pros
of what Black has established right
you've got pressure on the C file Allah
every Sicilian stream the Bishop on the
long diagonal with rooks pressure on the
dark
where's of the queenside is often what
you want in every dragon whether the
king is castled over here or not so for
evaluating you know what happened in
this particular dragon door if the one
thing I'm watching out for is this night
don't get it trapped on e5 but assuming
Maxime figures this out you know overall
this is this is the kind of position
where black has has achieved a very
double edged game he can play for a win
now all that said guess who I still
think is a little better here white way
and the main reason is that the bishop
here the pawn on d5 this is what we call
a marco hop structure the transition of
a night raid that happened on this move
14 opens up the e-file long-term and
what that means is eventually rook e1
comes each seven is a backward pawn in
these positions black is sort of hoping
for all these tactically good that
here's what I here's the problem I have
a black position you ready Robert yep
tell me tell me how to improve any of
these pieces they're on their best
squares right now and white hasn't even
been it's not close to optimal like you
make a trade you put the rook on e1 I
can play a four eventually kick your
nighty sevens week I feel like why do
you say much more to improve 97 9 f 6
Knight takes d5 will be my next three
moves okay first of all I'm not gonna
give you three moves Robert you ask me
how to improve the position I gave you
an answer now you're upset about ok 937
I'll play g5 first I'm gonna stop that
the play h4 I'm gonna get my e-file I'm
gonna bind you a lot of writing style
I'll take there's 8 on d4 and take your
pawn age 3 and then you're gonna be
upset about it ok fortunately may have
just lost the exchange tonight e - all
you have Knight of three check you lucky
dog I love your suggestion today okay
Wesley has has to find something here
I'll give it you know again the critical
point is that black has the pieces kind
of optimum optimally placed close to it
anyway and if you can start cashing in
then that's the key but my point was if
you gave white lots of time white still
had a lot more ways to positionally
improve than black did but maybe I'm
wrong maybe it looks like black is
actually getting the tension he needs
now so we'll find out thank God it's not
my game yeah I'm feeling the same way
but your ninety-two move is probably the
best but I agree with you about Knight
f3 check being the response
woodsey change exactly but I think it's
not the clearest exchange and that's
what by me normally does that kind of
lean back and look up when he's
skeptical of his opponents tactics just
watched him for for 10 days in Oslo
Norway and like it's just like a body
language thing you pick up like a car
Nakamura as many catalogues of faces
yeah it's kind of like it's he's not
sure but he just feels like there's
something off and normally like you know
when Magnus like went Full Tilt in the
last game with pushing the a pawn right
before he cashed in and took on b2 with
the bishop you know they get him talking
about he kind of you kind of did the
same thing I think it's a reminder he
does to tell himself to kind of stay
calm I think this is good for me and now
he by the way he goes for a 92 we'll see
if he can convert yeah I think you
predict this very well you're reading
the body language well and 9 f3 check
King to either C R and D 1 you gotta go
to c1 cuz otherwise we're d5 is check
and after Casey one group takes d5
Knight AC 3 Bishop takes c3 we're in a
bit of a messy position because it's a
typical dragon go ahead yet black is one
pawn and a knight for a rook yo and
white pawn a5 is a bit overextended on
h3 might become vulnerable but you're
absolutely correct it is a traditional
dragon sort of approach exchange down
but with massive amount of counter play
what are you thinking about here by the
way well he's probably confirming those
kind of variations you just I mean
Maxime is you know everything I'm Luke
takes III actually this is the same
piece he wants but if you take III
instead now I take with the F pawn to
stop knight of three check you're
picking up d5 I move my king I'm not
sure where you don't get the line you
talked about with the bishop on c3 so
ultimately he goes for that line and I
think it's because of the final position
we're seeing everyone Robert's idea of
the bishop on c3 is kind of key because
it hits a 5 Black has to keep the
pressure on in these dragon exchange
sacs why it's considering whether I can
play Bishop b6 or whether I give up the
a pawn which is I think the right
practical choice because if you can
force pieces off the board the rooks
chances of flexing on the
orthogonal orthogonal angles I didn't
even know what you were trying to say
but that Ord h o gon al is a word I
recently added to my vocabulary
orthogonal is when you're kids doing
geometry in school yes okay so the rook
chances of flexing post Malone style we
want to get him into whatever pre Malone
was or current Malone
but post Malone flex would be the rook
on open lines files those are the those
are the orthogonal angles the rook wants
to dominate oh man if I hear one more
math word from you I'm quitting for the
day I didn't sign up for a little
geometry lesson here hey you're welcome
I'll appreciate it later
okay but here come the here come the
angles there open up oh here comes a
bishop sitting on d6 like a nice
blockading piece and I liked it too
extra pawns the black ass you have taken
black hair okay I think you like the
material though I don't know I mean by
the way I've been sort of touting
White's
storyline White's perspective in this
game and and for a good reason I think
that you know with correct prep and
approach white is better but but I've
probably played these positions more as
black if we're actually talking about
personal experience so you know I think
two points the exchange is something but
what ends up happening the reason I
applauded the idea of giving up that
second pawn for the open lines is often
you you should prefer the right very the
right opening lines for your pieces over
small amounts of material and I don't
know I feel like White's not gonna lose
this game okay maybe black holds but I
don't think well I don't think white is
gonna be worse I agree I think that
white should be the only one with
serious winning chances unless something
goes very wrong
you can put your rook on d3 to protect
the b3 pawn you can just sit on the
position and there's no way for black to
team up and make progress and pieces f6
I guess he's trying to go king f7 and
then maybe key six but that feels yeah I
just look at the light squares I know I
even dark square bishop I gave you that
look I gave you this so look I was like
you're like please don't infiltrate
don't do it yep yeah I mean this here
comes h4 again more orthogonal angles
opening up but what if I take on h4
actually like take it for rook h1 Bishop
d3 I have Bishop a4 in the end Bishop f4
I see the pollen g5 I think you can't
put a Bhishma at 4 but of course with
constant H for now but now he'll trade
and he'll use the H file to to get in on
the action
yeah just there it goes d forces 30
Bishop takes f6 oh it was a nice trick
let me show it real quick analysis board
we go fish 54 was threatening things
like Bishop takes f6 and lights out 7 oh
whoa wait they just agreed to a draw yep
surprising you and me and everything I
mean let's show the final position
because Wesley just says you know what I
kind of you know I don't I don't have
enough I'm shocked I feel like only
white can push on with the rook okay
from a practical perspective what is
that what does that speak to you I think
just was he's very practical and he
realized this g4 pawn was a bit weak and
so he decided let me just make a drum
what is this opening what are we looking
at right now I'm sorry what is this I
can't do any idea this looks terrible
for white are you gonna say something or
you just know I'm I'm speechless right
now
it's a weird opening for sure and we
already saw him lose on the white side
of this particular English earlier not
not not exactly like this but we saw him
loose on the white side of one with the
the bad Queen sac game yeah we talked
about how with the two bishops you and
bad Pancho see you on open space there's
plenty of open space in this game and me
so easy from blacks play played Bishop
d6 Castle kings
I use your LightSquared Bishop because
white doesn't have one this is honestly
one of the worst openings I've seen I
love when you tell us how you really
feel
I mean I'm sort of angry honestly yeah
this is weird because we got a
LightSquared bishop and you don't have
one you you said it earlier and I'll
back you up cuz you were the first one
to call it that
one of the things we know Maxine has is
tilt potential we've seen it happen
before
and that was one thing I was worried
when I saw the dragon or played despite
the fact that ultimately ended in a draw
no and it was okay for him but I was
worried in the choice of openings
because I think if that continues to be
repeated the dragon door should be
played once and then forgotten yeah I
agree
and so we'll see where this goes
obviously if he can hold on here that's
another story but if we're just looking
at this objectively
he's down two points everyone maybe you
know it's okay to play it once I'm not
gonna call it a question roll opening it
was an interesting game but but now that
he's worse is white again and these
light squares are a problem um I'm gonna
put my bishop on it yeah you can put
your Bishop on f3 and ask white what
he's gonna do about it because even my
bishops it's planted on a great square
and menacing square or you let my Bishop
to retreat to d5 and okay obstacle
Bishop only it helps black because you
talk about this a lot when you have
obstacle bishops you wanna have firm
control of that color complex and if you
take it on d6 you're never gonna be able
to fend off my bishop on the white
squares right now I mean you can't black
just go for an attack f4 is coming Queen
d7 to h3 f4 might just be resigned bull
territory yeah this looks this looks
terrible I mean what did he do he did
everything wrong what did you do so I
just want to say like that it's okay I
forgive you here comes to h3 so he had
to play 92 but just Bishop d5 yeah keep
the bishop here because you go Queen age
20 to f3 still coming the light scores
are not solved just because you get to
pick the Bishop out and after Queen h3
field King h1 I can take on g3 point of
rook on f2 is your knight spin I mean
it's just oh you don't see a player
seen photographs caliber lose this kind
of miniature pretty much ever yeah this
is surprising and again the three-game
deficit now is what is what we you know
you kind of get worried about that's
what I was predicting with the dragon
that was that was weird
that was weird let's let's show the
analysis board again just real quick so
we can highlight why that was so weird
again we're rolling through this opening
and already with E for being played on
moved three or sorry move for caught
Roberts attention but then it was the
departure of the LightSquared Bishop on
c6
that had mr. Hess saying hey can't spell
chess without Hess and I don't like it
remember idea under statement of the
century he just crossed mean this is
like this position was resigned a bull
four moves and ultimately just got
crushed on the white squares I don't
even know what to say yeah I'm
exasperated okay he's down three games I
mean I think if this match stays closed
the bullet portion is is really where he
makes his move anyway but right now
you've you got to kind of pull yourself
together as you said if this match stays
close and look at this position for
black right now I mean is this the type
of chest you want to be playing I mean
for me yes for vaccine no it's the kind
of just I want him playing against me
tomorrow let's remind everybody of
what's on tap okay I would love to say
that was brought to you by someone but
it's not what is on on the agenda for
manana
it's the first ever adopted Danny show
am I looking at the disappointed face of
my new father who will win ten games
against me in multiple time controls or
is he looking at the face of a baby with
more potential than he can handle
so he tries to get rid of me that this
is this is going down a road I got to
pull myself back out of but anyway
Robert I know you'll be tuning in
tomorrow is the big dance me and Maxine
were throwing down in a battle and I
will not be adopted what time is your
battle tomorrow it's at 9:00 a.m.
Pacific thank you for asking that
and again the technical terms will be
announced it's actually already in the
article but the rules are you have to
win ten games in a row in a row in a
time control in order to adopt someone
he will be racing against the clock he
will have a certain amount of time to
try and adopt me before time runs out
but no segment can be ended on time so
if there is a if there is an adoption
streak that is still active I have to
defend it so what is that that Street is
one game I still have to defend it okay
so in other words you can't end the
segmental loss you need to at least draw
again yes okay well if maxi plays
tomorrow like he's playing right now I
mean how many ten be black too many is
the answer shout out to the donation
there we love it appreciate you um Queen
d7 rook t1 is gonna be another Tempe
I mean Knight b-52 c7 that also looks
pretty good yeah he goes work to you
well my only question was with a bishop
you for work but no it doesn't now you
now play might be from this is 12 moves
into a game what what is he doing right
now oh my gosh
he needs to chill let's let's rinse and
repeat back this thing up
replay style and show you why the
resignation happens the threat here
everyone is Knight to c7 check so you
make a move I play Knight c7 and you're
losing your queen cuz you're made it
otherwise this is this is like stuff you
you you you see in puzzle rush but not
in real Grandmaster games if you take
here white just takes on b5 with check
and the same problem occurs your king is
trapped on the D file and you're losing
the house on d7 there's there's no moves
there's no way there's no way to deal
with this so he resigns Robert yeah it
honestly looks like bullet games I play
when I lose because I'm playing terrible
openings and he Maxime is so much
stronger than this it's actually a
little upsetting for me to see but he's
got cz eating he's taking a bite
hopefully take some breath because what
he needs to do is just get one good game
yes bail he needs to stop
just playing risky openings for no other
reason than he's you can't play which
full chest you can't say I need to win
the game I want to win the game
so imagine isn't gonna win the game no
you just need to play your best moves
yep because of course Maxime is capable
of beating Wesley in a couple straight
games so that said I think Wesley of all
of the top players is great at keeping
his composure yep and that sometimes I
think hurts him a little bit for example
the candidates in 2018 when he lost his
first two games he could never get back
into it because he just was he's a
little out of it he was being he almost
too practical we started eating
victories too right jump up the
leaderboard and okay as maximum losing
beats ooh right now
yeah losing B 2 and then a 3 know what
to make of this now back to your point
about Wesley so I mean again as far as
we talked about this with Yasir and sofa
Co in Norway just his emotional his
ability to keep his emotions in check I
think it was it's one of things that
made him a very difficult opponent for
Yanomami Oishi right was that his
technical very kind of oh I don't want
to say dry but very very accurate
approach was something that kind of
called into question maybe some of the
combinations that Yann was going for
right and I think it made him a
difficult practical kind of matchup for
Nepal Miyoshi and I think here when when
Maxime is kind of on tilt not playing
his best here's what's not gonna happen
Wesley's not gonna beat himself so
you're either gonna pull yourself out of
this hole or not you know what I'm
saying right Wesley's not going to start
he's not gonna start messing around he's
not gonna lose his focus despite having
a four-game lead right yeah he is he's
amazing at that and a lot of job players
have complemented him whereas they feel
like you know I get a get in the
must-win territory to playing subjective
moves which is not playing chest it's
just a very objective game and Westie on
the other hand is just he takes his
breast he sits he relaxes and he gets
ready for the next one right now if you
look at this position it looks somewhat
promising for white because you see this
pawn on e5 and e6 but then you look at
the e5 pawn and notice that well it's
actually not defended you can go ahead
and take it right now so Knight takes e5
is a move just to get rid of this advant
chain well you could also can you get
away with b7 I guess rook b5 bishop of
three rook b8
okay maybe not okay he goes a6 I think I
think the point Robert where I was gonna
highlight is you don't even need to rush
taking e5 because
Harper white to fix that that doesn't
have defense you could play Bishop e7
now and try to take on f3 or tit yeah I
actually really like what Wesley did
with the Bishop e7 move order and I'm
with you right the punty 5 can only
protect you by some kind of Knight g4
move and then you put h5 and take the
night away so you're right
this oh so you thought Tundra Mike says
in the chest TV chat with fidei
acknowledging the Fischer random World
Chess Championship cycle the Fischer
random World Chess Champion should be
seated into the candidates along with
the previous challenger I like that idea
but not this year so is not gonna get
him but that's a cool idea for the
future too soon too soon
no but let's say of course they deserve
a champion there he's up to pawns now is
he about to go up 5 games it might be
six minutes for Maxime vache the Grove
in the five-minute portion if you're
just tuning in good for you because we
still have two full hours of amazing
chess up ahead two of the best players
in the world throwing down we have more
than 12,000 of you across actually
almost 13,000 right now no matter where
you're tuning in from YouTube twitch
facebook twitter thanks for making us a
part of your day this is chess TV and we
are here to serve you by the way that
was awkward
but thanks for let me do it appreciate
it okay Wesley so by the way threatening
Queen takes g3 watch out
that's an f2 pond that's pinned and he
has to play King f1 to unpin it Oh
honestly I wasn't even looking the g3
sports I'm glad you pointed out and I
know it's rare that I comment you and
note that you're pointing things along
swimmingly today like I think I think
you're right we have been it's just cuz
we miss each other so much no you know
such a good time what do you do with the
decision to trade rooks off the board I
think it actually worsens those winning
chances I agree yeah but Dani no I'm
about to point out what Bishop yep look
at the H one corner dark square bishop
which means that if Y is able to
you sacrifice a piece for some of these
pawns and leave this H pawn yeah dark
squared Bishop H one corner and actually
I know I always say that and some people
like why does Robert always mention it
wait a second this is now pure obstacle
mission now I don't think this is gonna
be winning
yeah because wait no but there's the
Bishop e1 backdoor problem that have so
the issue here for Maxime is despite the
obstacles ship these pawns being stuck
to dark squares everyone leave them look
he just resigned yeah he's over it yeah
I was gonna say that so I think Robert I
agreed the rook trade hurt winning
chances but the knight trade helped it
and let me bring up the analysis board
to kind of show why the resignation
happens the main point here is that
these weaknesses on dark squares aren't
going anywhere again we talked about
that obstacle bishops by definition
means look but don't touch
these guys will forever be dancing
around each other and that means if you
have weaknesses on the color of your
opponent's Bishop you're in big trouble
so if the King is permanently stuck over
here - let's say stop that well guess
what now it's uh just a free walk for
the black King because this guy's
forever out of the day and I'm just
gonna win over here because of my C pawn
so that was okay honestly I didn't
expect it to end so quickly Robert but
that was excellent technique yet again
by Wesley so who with a five-game lead
is is blowing mines right now we see
some hot fire so everywhere hot fire
yeah well when you get into an endgame
like that as we're discussing one of the
things that white wants to do is trade
off pawns because you've opposite
colored bishops yeah your opponent can't
control the other color complex and
blacks pawns were on light squares which
means the bishop could have kind of
operated and try to attack those pawns
from behind in an ideal scenario so G
for g5 was definitely the wrong idea for
Maxime but okay he's fully until tomoow
he's playing a French so hopefully that
helps him because he is a Frenchman he's
playing the French you know how we feel
about the French here yes commentators
f5 feels like an open attack or Wesley
or if I'm if I'm Y I'll play Queen e2
and just hope you missed Bishop takes h7
you know how I love a Greek gift
yeah it's degrees Bob actually no
souvlaki for you yeah oh it goes for it
yes Queen d3 it actually works here cuz
you get the tempo with a ch3
oh dude I either Berta Lee called it
wait what if I go rook f e8 or work f d8
but I still get Queen h7 I check and
pick up g7 and the attack is on dude
okay first of all let's show the
analysis board for everyone why this is
a tactic I had on my brain again this is
pattern recognition you just have to
know whatever you have a pawn on e5 by
definition in a French structure that
should be mean there's no knight on f6
which therefore means you have to always
keep an eye out on these pawns now
typically it doesn't work in this
forcing manner unless the queen is
immediately on the light square diagonal
but in this particular position he's
able to do it and then bring the Queen
to the diagonal with tempo because the
third-ranked is completely clear so for
example if g6 had been played watch out
Queen age three now and you move the
rook it's just matin - this is a very
very common mating net and so Maxime did
the best thing which is to move the rook
away but after check all and even Queen
h5 even more accurate it's just over it
says just sick bro oh you a six point
lead in the speeches championship and
then we get an F for dude we almost saw
Wesley smiled there the thing is you
know how humble Wesley is ah yeah and
for f5 was played did you see that what
is going on here oh wow max team is on
full tilt full tilt but why did Wesley
play f5 I think what's he likes a good
opening joke yeah we've seen this in
several occasions where but I think it's
Mammadov when he played like eight it
was like eight for a five or something
like that or eight eight three eight h6
what was it it was some ridiculous
opening but Wesley has good fun when his
opponents are playing these offbeat
lines and I feel like Maxime obviously
Full Tilt and as we see in the ticker he
had a four-game comeback against Wei Yi
yeah but six games against Wesley so
some games would be officially record
territory if you're keeping
tract so anything's possible and records
are made to be broken but let's just say
it might be good for max seems emotional
well-being that he gets to play me
tomorrow huh I don't think this is a
good chance for him though this game
because if he can win this game
yeah and then say go +2 in the 3 minute
portion and end up minus 3 ok ok still
got a chance so right now just go for
the attack like Bishop g5 by 94 in some
order you know he's gonna do all these
moves but rookie 1 now hitting east 6
threatening the f5 mid Queen e2 is
better in the pond officially this will
be the last game of the 5 minute portion
everyone you see time about to run out
we will take a very quick break and then
the 3-1 that begins so don't go anywhere
still lots of chess ahead and Maxine
Bochy magrav we know he's one of the
best chess players and world most likely
gonna be playing in the candidates to
try to compete for the World Chess
Championship challenger spot so it's not
often you get to see this kind of view
and stay tuned because it may get
interesting
all right nice e6 Wesley trying to
defend that given that he has this
two-point advantage and I don't know
I'm not feeling I'm not feeling this
sack well he's gonna get a rook a te one
situation going where he's in taken f5
so either take on c6 for a number k d1
now I have 5 is hanging and he
definitely compensation here because
there's only gonna be a one pawn deficit
after White's next move okay that's the
case with an open King sir yes I admit I
underestimated how dangerous White's
position was with the Knights still
being traded I kind of like made this
assumption that if the knight is traded
on c6 White's compensation must be to
Wendling but you're right
this is still very dangerous for black
yep and he's up 40 seconds on the clock
and when you're tilting right all the
times you're tilting in a very negative
direction yeah but sometimes you get on
the win and you go on a winning streak
and then everything feels much better I
mean we saw our tamiya do this against
Levon Aronian right LaVon got off to a
two or three game lead in that match as
well and then our Timmy have just went
on an absolute tear and finished up
seven points by the end of the match he
won 16 to 9 yeah but you're back
again it's really hard to do that
against Wesley self further
characteristics we've described he
doesn't he very rarely goes on tilt
right which as you said can can
sometimes be a drawback but most the
time it's a huge plus in his favor
because chess is so objective and he
keeps himself calm so alright but Maxime
all all that matters is you got him in
one and looks like he's he's about to be
on the attack what exactly take back
enough six Queens five check for EDF 194
the attack sort of plays itself and the
defense is not very easy
so what C and looking like in some
trouble here he takes the rule out no
that can't be good maybe a good decision
actually forget for one here I just hit
the Queen get the f6 squared for your
Bishop fourth second 85 at some moment
if the King stays there too long I think
we're good for one is a move to get that
about educated you know there's
also Queen c4 oh he's lead it right
after I called it I called it hit c6 you
and Maxie murders in the same page just
like I mean that's that's so good for me
not him then we played the same level of
chess right now you have to count some
Queen side of things which is
scary-looking move but yeah the point
everybody is that was a fork of the g8
rook and the c6 pawn with it more
devastating things to follow but that
means Queen c4 was good
now what can he do so the point is if
you go to h6 there's like what Queen g6
and you know that's a fork that's a fork
a double attack you attack more than one
piece at a time and bad things often
happen actually
so maybe my Queen c4 was no good Oh
silly magazine never go for rivals you
know interesting and once Council Queen
set happens and you start and think for
however many seconds thank you for now
40 seconds or so never a good sign never
a good sign the Dino experience is once
white takes and c6 that protects the g2
square so like Bishop h6 Queen g6 and
we're saying Queen takes c6 protects the
maid
yeah also might lead to a vicious attack
that's that's gonna be the key point and
that's why he's calculating let's show
that on the analysis board so okay hey
he plays rook f1 first but the point is
at some point here you probably are
losing this bishop but trying to get a
nasty attack here the problem is if
you'd come up short then Wesley so will
once again have been so amazing I mean
this is with the one game where Mexican
just had to win not just because of the
score but the position is two pieces for
rook beat c4 was too fancy I don't hear
just rubbing it in because I suggested
it no I really I'm kidding but no it
really it was too fancy it looked better
than if I was rubbing it I would have
done it immediately and much more
harshly right and it seems like I might
be doing that that's why we love it
doesn't it just goes to show that these
kind of attacks that are hitting c6
hitting G at the same time is sort of if
it works it works there's a one move
threat that can be dodged by them like
castling queenside but they don't have a
concrete follow up it's one of those you
probably want to avoid but this happens
all the time
I've seen to happen so many times to my
students to myself where I get in love
with a certain concept and then I don't
really think about the actual
consequences besides the fact that it
looks good and it should be something
without finding it in concrete and
losing to make it draw by checking if
King b8 he can have perpetual if Wesley
wants more and he's really feeling his
yeah he's feeling his chance to get a I
can't believe I'm gonna say this eight
point lead
wait seven that's why I can't say it
seven point lead you know all this
geometry but what he said nobody claimed
you were doing man
geometry is not real math I'm not gonna
get in this debate with you right now
you know it is matte though smarter
chests odds and did he predict us know
so I'm once again I'm but he did predict
so was the favorite yeah but not like
this well they nobody did although I'll
give smarter chefs some credit because
in our private chat that the staff has I
can say that Matt he and again I'm gonna
say it now in hopes that
wrong and then I'm jinxing his
prediction but he said not only does he
think so is the favorite Matt Jensen
said he believes this match has run away
potential because of Mack seems history
of tilting and and by the way I have
that on record he said that before the
match started so unfortunately for all
of us out there the smarter chess
prediction making me look dumb we're
gonna take a very quick break when we
come back the 3-1 portion gets underway
Ivana Gras versus so the speeches
championship action when we return and
we are back with the 2019 speech as
championship in a match that has been
hotly anticipated to the biggest names
in the world but right now kind of
surprising us with where it's going
despite what our predictions said would
happen Robert we've got we've got a
runaway and maybe not for the player
that a lot of people expected yeah I
mean Wesley so was the favorite player
in the longer time controls based on
smart justice that's the history of the
speechless championship but this is just
out of hand
we have seen Mexi priscilla grove tilts
in previous speeches champ to matchups
but Wesley so keeping his composure
letting his opponent tilt and not being
distracted by me that he has now surged
out to a six game lead very impressive
stuff well and there you have the stats
and just to show how shocking it is
again our predictions did have Wesley so
as the favorite even though I kind of
disagreed with them I thought Maxine was
the favorite as I said a sight we can't
really mention those types of sites or
encourage anybody to use them but there
are sites that run lines a la you know
the kind of Vegas prop bets things that
exist people do that sort of thing and
they also had Maxine Bosch a lagravis a
favorite so we're not alone in terms of
you know when there's actual money on
the line I think a lot of people felt
that this was much closer to a toss-up
and maybe it will be the the match is
young we still have 60 minutes ahead of
three minutes yes and then of course a
half an hour Bolin and as well I didn't
expect it would ever be this big of a
lead for so I said if even if Maxime is
trailing a little bit heading into
bullet I still might consider him the
favorite so before games get underway we
want to actually bring up our daily
question because it was brought to our
attention how much you have a
controversial issue this might be in our
speeches championship form
because we're working with players it's
such a busy calendar year in 2019
it's a Grand Prix year a grand chest
tour year it's so much going on
ding li Ren played yesterday very very
late for him in China but Wesley so is
playing from India way out of his normal
timezone and by the time this match is
done it'll be about what it was for ding
Li Ren about 1:30 2:00 a.m. in India
right now he's playing very well so
Robert
anyway let's run through these these
tweets and see what people think we have
one comment here from Zephyrs AK 9 says
there's evidence the mind is sharper and
less reliant on heuristics during
different parts of the days ok so
science coming at us there
Jacob Fitzgerald says they could
definitely give an advantage due to
tiredness or distraction but that are a
function of time or distractions that
are a function of time learner I don't
know how I've misread that my bad
Jacob music a lot of Jacob's Robert you
know we almost named you Jacob by the
way if both players prepare by adjusting
their sleep schedule in advance there
should be no advantage to any side what
do you think Jacob was you asking my
opinion now I'm calling me Jacob because
it's not particularly funny anyway we
the games are gonna begin here any
second but Robert your thoughts on what
we saw there from the comments sale on
Twitter use the hashtag speech yes if
you still want to get your opinion heard
and your thoughts on how Wesley so is
playing despite being way out of way
past his bedtime
I don't know Richard it's hard to say
what uh what time of day is best for it
to play chess but no I think that it
does matter if you are out of your
comfort zone Dingley rent for example he
said he's never played chess that late
before but players who are used to
staying up very late and just playing an
hours of blitz on end
they won't struggle as much I think the
more online experience you have in
general the less it matters what time
you're playing ok that's fair right and
obviously it's a discussion we like to
hit controversial points on the head so
those who were critical of us yesterday
and Dingley been playing a little bit
out of his time zone like I said we're
doing our best with a global event with
players coming in from all over the
world and a very busy schedule today
we're doing the same thing with Wesley
right now it doesn't seem to matter and
I you know I will see what ends up
happening here but that was an amazing
stat right there about how dominant
Wesley so has been in the three minute
portion Robert yeah he's been an
absolute monster and well if Maxime
keeps playing the way he hasn't playing
it's going to be trouble for him but
right now this is a very complicated
type of position yeah do you always
think white is better you have more
space your pieces are all fully
developed there's a bishop on Cedarbrook
I need that not into the action yet
white trades off one pair of rooks
brings the rook to d1 yeah and well now
might be the time to play Bishop d7 and
finally finishing development
development unless I'd the poison but
here white has to have a little bit of
an edge because of the open file we have
an open file dominated by by white here
which maybe leads to some back ranked
tactics it to be careful about it was
easy calculating some way to take
advantage of d7 here well Bishop takes
f6 runs right into Bishop takes f6 with
the Queen under attack so you're not
getting away with it and well black goes
Bishop c6 next and then follows up with
a move even like Bishop c7 it feels like
the worst is certainly behind black in
such a situation yeah I'm with you
actually and speaking of open files
Black's about to get his rook on one
here so this is the kind of Sicilian
counter play we see white first to the
center of a black hoping for the opening
opening for the opening opening for the
opening f5 look at that if Weiss he just
you know he's just pushing forward and
the point is that if you take on f5 this
isn't just any old free pawn because
then your ideas rook takes d7 it's just
game over
well it's out but I guess oh yeah f7 I'm
sorry lol and then last but yes you know
sometimes cool people these days they
just say lol instead of laughing got it
I missed that memo but maybe next time
oh sorry my bad
if I played now he owned IG for now the
thing is it doesn't actually win
material because you can take d8 with
Tempe you also hit the Queen but Wesley
decides to just maintain the tension
I thought maybe Queen III check was
coming at the end of that line but I
guess white would have the seventh ring
so no yeah so instead he's played no.6
protecting the bishop now f5 actually
can be captured if you take on e6 simply
take back with the fish 26 and it looks
like black has neutralized most of
White's initiative so in our faster time
quit chill here right now neither side
with a big edge on the clock but Maxine
with a little bit a few more seconds if
we're really keeping track surprised by
that yes you know he's anticipating
rubber babies anticipating the endgame
and wants the King to have a quick entry
in this pawn to already be past I guess
that's nothing plausible and actually
move like 94 now might speak to that
point because okay I like your move his
E okay but the the reason we were
questioning taking with upon everyone is
because if you don't get the endgame
opening up the king like this and then
the fact that the e6 pawn is a target
may backfire and we see Wesley now
playing very aggressive I think if this
Knight moves he'll actually deny the
trade maybe something like 94 oh I'm
wrong there we go
big surprise he decides the endgame is
good but even here I mean it's still
like white white is probably no longer
in danger of being on the worst side of
this at all
white is just better because a black
king is in danger and it can't really
get out so at any moment the rook me why
do you give the a4 that was surprising
me I thought he was going to protect
that pawn and then played rook up for
one and things like this I don't think
you wanted to trade off the rooks
because now blacks team will feel much
much safer is at the very worse will be
a bunch of checks but no devastating
threats yo take enough up at Queen c6
here yesterday you're holding everything
you've guarded c8 e 6 ei d5 so should be
a draw still slightly better for white
because you have more space to operate
with
and the black king can't really escape
the box right but if you can't create a
clear pass on then who cares with your
King can't move out you shuffle back and
forth as they say the advantage is
probably just symbolic here for white
given that yes you have the optically
better place Queen right and as Robert
said the king is gonna cut but likely
with neither side having any any real
weaknesses to speak of should be kind of
a shuffle puck for a draw oh wait we
decided shuffle puck it's not a thing
that was my bad yeah you were told that
by some angry yeah yeah that's right
Michelle isn't fake well no knuckle
puck is Mighty Ducks three Disney please
don't sue us
oh that's shuffleboard shuffleboard yeah
shuffle pause just something I made up
anyway yep good talk back and forth back
and forth we're gonna tickle this one
out Tickle Me Elmo here it's gonna be a
draw although this King is very active
yet and and I do want to highlight what
so is doing because what what you get in
these end games where the King comes out
everyone is the potential at some point
to trade Queens and suddenly you're in a
king upon anything that you can win but
wait first he should have been King a
fight first
oh he just shakes his head Wesley has
made his first blunder of the match with
that move yeah first retrospect it's so
obvious we're gonna we're gonna let them
finish out cuz I want to see Maxime win
this ending which he's about to do with
he's gonna bring the king up and then
he'll use these two to create what's
called an outside passed pawn and then
ultimately win and then we're gonna show
we're gonna show that moment and how
instructive it was cuz Wesley was
literally on pace for us to applaud him
with the active King and now you see
head in hand he knows he's raw Danny
it's a draw what no then I go King D
four and then a five first then King C
for aa and if B five first B for yep to
the Batcave let's show what happened so
okay first everyone Wesley
shaking his head because he blew the win
right here the point is when you bring
your King up very actively well we were
gonna highlight is at some point if
black just sits now you've taken your
king from all the way over here right
all the way up here so that suddenly a
queen trade is just an easily winning
king upon ending so it's it's dangerous
and kind of weird to bring the king out
with the Queen still on the board but
here this was a really good example of
why a centralized and dominant queen is
so good because it kind of it kind of
makes the King's journey to up the board
safe but here he gives checked too soon
thinking he already got good enough he
was he was hoping for King g7 king c5
and he's winning what he missed was this
very nice defensive fine b6 and the king
has shut out and I thought I thought
black was winning now and I'll show why
the point was I thought at some point
black gets here and the point is you
let's say you do this and white doesn't
play b4 eventually you create this
outside pass pawn you sacrifice it and
in the end your king is closer this is
just King and pawn endings kind of 101
but Robert pointed out why I'm an
international master and he's a
grandmaster because that's not exactly
what will happen here the point is if b5
is played then b4 and it's still locked
up and if 85 is played then King c4 so
actually the reason these guys just kind
of shuffle puck to this one home is
because neither side can really actually
make progress so there you go Robert how
was that analysis session that was great
I paid attention almost none of it no
I'm just kidding that was that was
really good no you explained exactly why
at first glance it looks like blacks
should be winning because you've the
outside pawns but in fact it's a move by
move situation where it's very concrete
and in fact doesn't work however
maxime might not have gotten away with
the win in the last game in this games
position looks excellent because white
is barreling down at this pawn on e5
this move before not only threatens pawn
to b5 to take the night away from the
defense the e5 pawn but also threatens
Knight to c5 hopping into the action
protecting d3 attacking b7 and e6
simultaneously and move like b6 is a
move that you typically do not want to
play for black because look at that bish
bunchy - yeah it's a bishop on the long
diagonal unopposed and so white's pieces
are just better black
ponds are looser this should be max max
seems game for the taking he has to find
a real knockout blow and he started 95
of course is a good move yeah let's I
want to bring up the Batcave real quick
because while I was instructing on the
kingdom pawn ending I missed the opening
so how did Maxime gets this is the best
opening we've seen him having in a while
right yeah maybe I'll match I mean maybe
I'll match and lucky but he he went
really kind of just off the beaten path
plays a a Kings Indian attack and so
takes this sort of weird weird a fee and
Ketel response but really I guess it
gets wild with f5 I guess that five is
probably the move so we'll be regretting
because that just over extends and as
Robert said and the current structure e
5 is such an easy target here comes
Queen b3 you've got diagonal problems
I'm with you I like I like Mike seems
chances here so and there as 90s b7
working here it does not work well my
dear by nineteen b7 it's like c5 with
check on my next move but if you play 90
HP 7 Bishop d7 c5 check this Queenie six
which saves the day so it looks like
black barely gets out of that one and
all right d4 played to say well you
can't take me on d4 your rook on e8 is
under attack back there and alright and
yeah well I know what to make of this
because now both sides are gaining
activity black kids control the e5
square white is advancing that D pawn to
e3 to d5 in which case well I think it's
helpful for black because now at least
you have some life in the position they
see d5 was a good move so Wesley I think
picking up some momentum the position
but it's very complex a lot of pieces
concentrate in the center and well
there's they're going to be tactics here
that's for sure yep and all right two
bishops for white the f5 pawn now
vulnerable how do you actually protect
that pawn queen f8 Wow not a movie you
typically think of right away can I sack
when that takes a five take on e4 next
probably not then all my pieces so I'm
glad to do it
but that's how I would blow the
advantage here would be unnecessarily
sacking I have rubbed off on you so much
yeah well you know me I always say if
they're not my pieces I'm happy to we
owe
check Rigsby wait e seven check Queen f7
okay
like I'm like missing all the action
here because I think you 7 just wins a
rook because if you take my queen on b3
I take yours in that favor check after
seven years blocked with your queen f7
so I mean II seven would win a rook for
everyone's tactics if that line happened
Robert wasn't wrong about that but the
point is that he's seven just Queen f7
and black is okay so I Maxime is still
much better here but he hasn't been able
to convert yet so yeah well we've got to
give a real quick shout-out that we just
had a two thousand dollar donation from
a gas trader in honor of getting the
femme fatale kind of charity charity
activities going so one of the big
things about this match everyone is not
only is it for fun and there's prize
money on the line for the ladies to
compete for but it's also a charity
stream and they are raising money for
charity so a two thousand dollar
donation for hype one that should be
more of a reason for everyone to stick
around after the show make sure you
watch the femme fatale matchup which is
coming up right after this SEC match but
also amazing donation there Wow two
thousand dollars that's a lot of money
and thanks for that and looking forward
to everything that happens there so
there you go yep that's gonna be a lot
of fun we already point out who we
thought were the slight favorite
favorites yep okay white is trying to
work the bishop pair now is the new
advantage in the position but you got to
give so credit because if we were
evaluating what was going on earlier
Robert with that overextended Center in
E 5 being a weakness that did not happen
here yeah what did in fact Wesley is
probably just better now as black he
looks about as confused as we feel he's
like how did I get this position hey all
of a sudden black is the one with passed
pawn here yep and his but also up to
pawns everything collapsed yeah black
broke through and ended up using the
center with the two knights so Wesley
pretty good at this three-minute chess
thing as we pointed out in the stats
earlier he has he has
basically dominated the 3-1 segments in
his SEC history including winning the
3-1 segment against Magnus Carlsen a
match he lost so this particular segment
even when he goes down tends to be where
he kind of hangs his hat yeah and he is
he's playing well right now up on the
clock against max he won Rookie one wins
immediate rookie was just game over and
he's and he look at that head nod he's
like yo did you see that I just played
rookie 1 just could we get a gif of that
so like I mean that was insane I don't
even know what to say he's got a
seven-point lead
that's what to say Wesley so in blitz is
as good as it gets I mean for those who
remember even against a Cara Nakamura in
the speech has championship championship
like the final match last year I believe
Wesley either drew or even won that
segment ultimately he'd lost that match
and I think he was - - and bullet but
again the jokes about Wesley being a
very strong blitz player
they're not real I know I mean there's
not a joke yeah I don't know who would
ever say that he's not he tied his car
Nakamura believed 5 5 in both the
five-minute and three-minute segments
and lost a tight match in the bullet
right and Wes he lost his first game of
this match if you remember Danny and we
were ok off to a shaky start and then
since then just been Wesley dominance
who's he think he is the Boston Celtics
of this year losing Game one and then
just going on a tear right did you
purposely well stuff bring that up
because they beat my son's last night
was that what you did you know we're
moving on now past the Celtics okay I
get it yeah alright what's going on here
this is a kind of weird sort of reversed
Carlsbad kind of structure here you've
got this normal qgd structure that black
often has and and white normally has the
minority attack with things like b5 and
B 4 on the agenda to try to undermine d4
but here that that's kind of a black
house so you can't play b5 right away
for
these reasons well actually wait so
first two questions Robert it was b5
possible and why isn't d5 hanging what
am I missing
Queen trapped but this should ease but
then clean g5o
I wanted you to complete my sandwich
there you go there you know I ate that
sandwich before the match yeah no but I
didn't understand why that plan wasn't
hanging maybe he'll regret it but I
think it might have been hanging a move
before - he just goes in and steals it
and I think it was a good idea I'm kind
of greedy Yassir has taught me well
Yassir loves to steal pawns and that
Queen is still in harm's way Bishop h6
the only one who's queen g4 and there's
no discovery with that Knight
that's unreal it's so weird I mean we
got to analyze that real quick to show a
Robert Simon Bishop h6 queen g4 and this
is the kind of position where you're
just you're staring death in the face
but living to tell about it there's no
powerful discovery by the knight 93 you
know you got nothing
Knight takes d4 you actually lose a
piece just it again if you're Maxime you
got to be irritated about that but it
looks like Wesley just stole that pawn
and and got away with it
Wow I mean it looks still looks somewhat
risk nice c4 so you know once they can
just trade everything yeah he's trying
to play against this backwards C pawn
but is it enough right you're a pawn so
it's hard to just settle on a positional
approach of hitting the C pawn I mean
now Wesley I mean he just moves like g4
to Cano g4 Bishop e6 haha resid yourself
the boat s gambit yep and well the
tackle the C pawn is real work fc8 o
rook takes c3 hits the nine f3 so that's
all very nice Wow
maxime swindling his way back into the
game I love it and I wanted to play
Bishop h6 but probably just rate
everything and take d4 can you get away
with that you can also take d4 right
away now that you mention it
because 94 rooks III just rooks III back
and there's all these discoveries in the
Queen if you try to take on c3 yeah
pretty nice stuff I'd rather keep the C
file closed from your pieces because if
I take on c1 you'll have some back rank
checks oh I'd like to do first yeah
Intermezzo you're threatening things
like Knight takes up three now you can
take probably with the bishop keep the
Queen's on the board
yeah yep okay and very important bishop
g3 is never possible to protect the pawn
1 F 2 cos its opponents whose pins
overtakes you do it via free piece and
if you can't protect this pawn on f2 you
vroop takes east 7 looking like an
option the problem there is actually
what is the problem
oh my gosh
maybe there's Bishop F to check Queen F
to rip c1 check King G to the Queen c6
chat oh sweet
and if you're free Brooksie free and if
Queen f3 Brooke c2 and the boys that are
King G through at Queen d6 check ah you
just pick him up well Wesley took the
pawn he was kind of like I'm gonna call
max Eames Bluff here but this might be
one he regrets
yeah Maxime spot the move - yep I don't
see it first clash like let me just open
up this King and there has to be
something here but there are no
defenders in front of this King so
mission of 2 works out but what's funny
is you could play King f1 and it's and
it's not over it and black also has like
crazy dark square problems to worry
about rookie ape it should be 5 so
Wesley taking his time here we're gonna
see that the scramble commenced oh he
goes for this okay maybe there was some
problem with king of one I thought maybe
he would settle on that idea but instead
he walks up he loses the rook shakes his
head and guess what max team Bochy the
grog wins his first game since this
match started if you're one of the still
roughly twelve thousand viewers here in
English many more across
all of our international partners thank
you so much for being here this is the
2019 speech Chess Championship clearly
it is a Wesley so kind of day but that
was a big win big huge and unique from
Maxime you need to keep it up you can't
just have that be a one-off event he won
the first game he won that game and
given 16 but you can't have this kind of
spread between victories so yeah we like
this position the first time around with
this opening I think it was Game three
if I'm not mistaken
where was the end of winning upon and
then back seems somehow like Bishop
versus night ending yeah with the rooks
on the board and so he's going for the
same exact plan but with three minutes
the clock rather than five and I think
that with the few minutes in the book on
the clock excuse me I do think that
favor is white in these more aggressive
structures because black always be
considering is there a sacrifice so it
to happen the East six square is d5 yon
app and let's open up the bish run b2 so
you're saying no trades here make it a
little easier for black no I was saying
the opposite oh I was saying I mean Nana
said the trades I'm setting the clock
situation with also what's happening on
the board I think it's harder to play
this as black the mrs. white at least
that's my take on the position because I
move like d5 right now or in the future
is always a scary proposition okay yeah
that's interesting I mean normally I
would say that the minor piece trades
when you're playing any kind of by QP or
hanging pawn structure favor the person
playing against the pawns but guys with
less mature on the board but in this
particular situation I hear you're
saying so just the one night trade
actually kind of helps white it
clarifies things now you can put the
rook on d1 you're trying to punch d5
through so I feel you I feel you I mean
I disagree I mean I was more talking
about the clock and board combination
rather than the specifics of the
position by anytime this move d5 comes
in you have to be a little bit concerned
about if that past ball can roll for
right it is one of those off its the
debate of these structures right because
is it a is it a strength or is it a
weakness its isolated but its past right
okay well now now I think I we have both
immediately we're like 'if I'm not sure
about that now we love White's position
now that D Pont is anchored the dark
squares d6 is calling my name by the way
can I just play 987 yep
and he did you weren't full of Timothy
Xiaomei there he did he's gonna go
knight c6 and he's gonna have a
protected okay no longer protected but a
powerful pass pawn and the light square
bishop
he's your g3 I think that's okay but if
g3 Queen c6 Bishop g2 e4 maybe after
your queen ceases gonna take on e5 first
I think I have to okay there we go
that works okay if g3 queen c6 e 5 is
taken first and then the threat of
Bishop g2 is bananas there also I mean I
guess Queen a4 what's your response to
Queen a4
just trying to alright c5 Wow he's a
look like Queen b7 it looks like protect
this pawn yeah he's also got spying on
f7 if you take he might play like Bishop
c4 mmm just try to overwhelm the light
score so that c6 can't be taken yeah
he's really going for adventurous play
an aggressive play here yeah he went
Queen b7 okay be like so how can black
kind of stave off the pressure here if
you take on b7 and give me a pawn of b7
I you have to work a 7 there otherwise
I'm taking on a 6 and you're in trouble
but still feels like a dangerous
situation for black yeah if I was
hanging but the problem is at b7 Falls
this is most the company supplies
advantage go with it you can get a 6 so
the question is can you like take e5
that's what he's gonna do and if you
take he takes a 6 I think yeah okay so
he's answering my question about as
quickly as I'm highlighting and the
point is if R okay seven I can guard
if Brooke e7 i can play Bishop c3 and if
everybody's traded I should be better in
this hanging with the Past a pawn in the
bishop pair yeah outside passed pawns
are great in the endgame and here
a pawn of course is more outside than a
sea bonus so but is there something that
Wesley can do right now q by night and I
cannot buy 94 answered my own question
we're trying to figure out if I can
trade the dark square bishop because
Bishop to bishops advantage is great
when it's a bishop pair but the issue is
when you've a bishop versus a knight
sometimes wait what about just take on
just an Bishop b5 yes you got out but
what I was going to say is let's say
this game continues and this knight can
go from E 4 to D for the bishop when the
light squares can't touch the knight on
a dark square so that is essentially
blacks plan here why didn't he play
Bishop c6 it's interesting anyway
diamond member of Leki 333 and the chess
TV chat wants to know if so is playing
from India as you saw in that stat he's
playing from India it's late and he just
enjoyed some curry I wasn't seeing me
yep nice that's making me hungry just
Panang curry right ok so wait is white
going up oh look at this
Wesley is so smart rookie 7 you take on
c5 yep Knight takes B 585 King d6
and your king is just in time to draw
attached to the b-pawn exactly yeah I
don't think Black has lost any more I
think he swindled his self into an equal
in game and he's gonna hold it again
this is why Wesley so hard to make a
comeback against I mean he's a good
chess player of regardless but you said
max team needs to make sure that victory
wasn't one-off right Robert and then you
outplay him and you feel like all you
need is that two games in a row give me
some give me some momentum and Wesley
says I'll feed you baby birds feed you
with something wrong knowledge I think
we can do it dikembe mutombo well he
also shakes his fingers it's not my
house and then he says I'll feed you
some knowledge and anyway he's just a
great guy all around Wesley so and this
kind of position I would say at first
glance looks a bit scary for black
because your King has to be distracted
the Queen side while white is going to
move up the board the issue for white is
well the black Kane gets back to slow
too slow because King c5 you play king
alfor then f6 and then after g5
do you take taking kingi for King h6
King F free oh wait no wait when's that
wait my nether King F 4 F 6 g5 you might
be able just go King D 6 back and I
think you have that's key king of for F
6 g 5 king d5 let him take and then King
e6 draw no no no that's bad after king
d6 GF 6 do you put H 6 to keep the King
out of g5 that's very important okay
yeah yeah so takes h 6 the king is
frozen
let it go Elsa no room to move forward
King e6 okay this also works draw that
was uh that was good technique now
normally again let's go to the Batcave
normally this is what we would tell our
students in terms of how to win these
kind of men games you got this outside
pass pawn which very rarely becomes the
pawn that actually Queen's it's always
the decoy so that their King is farther
away than yours but Wesley of course
knows his end games and knows that well
normally true he's just in the nick of
time especially with this accurate
Robert has h6 move with no interest
points it's just gonna be a dead draw
King and 2 versus King at 2 so there you
go how do you how do you stay in mac
seems kind of corner here robert you put
your coach hat on give him some
encouragement how does he how does he
come back here after that he's one and a
half out of his last two games which
means that well as a + score if you
ignore the previous games before that
yes oh he's still fighting he's some
claim pretty well there's about half an
hour left in this time segment win just
focus on every single move that one by
one and if you can win this game you cut
the lead to five and you feel much
better than it was up to seven points
yeah right so just you need to start an
upward trend that's that's essential and
well this position for example II played
d4 after knife there's no g5 yeah break
the okay this is the aggressive live
rook e8 yep put pressure so essentially
your advice was just keep swimming Dory
right that's keep swimming and if you
look at the time situation you're up 25
seconds so keep playing good moves and
play them quickly and that sounds
Robert obviously I want to play the best
movers and play them as fast as possible
but in a position like this where Maxime
should feel quite comfortable
you should not overthink the position he
should trust himself he's a very very
strong player make me was like queen g6
think about hitting the c2 pawn they put
you know this one of the Ruxin d8 if
necessary moving the night long f4 is
very good I was gonna say but you have
to love it not even like the reason
Robert I love that move is okay one
objectively you have the bishop here you
want to open the dark scores against the
King but just from a practical point of
view we love that move right that's so
being like I'm in the lead here I'm
gonna make this thing sharp and I'm not
afraid to you know do what I think is
objectively best even if I'm trying to
protect a lead he's just gonna go for
the attack on the dark scores you know I
love that yeah I think Queenie six I
mean he was trying to go to e too but
somehow the McQueen being away from the
g5 pawn makes me a little bit nervous
yeah and he'll have to play queen g6
it's well I guess I can't really a
Bishop d3 Queen d3 if he's like getting
into six well maybe she'd do that
actually Bishop d3 queen d3 queen g6
just trade Queens off and be slightly
worse but nothing too major well he may
end up going for something like that
anyway because you don't want the attack
to get strong against your open king so
looking to get the Queen's off the board
maybe Queen g6 next move you kind of
want to okay he takes first and here
comes your queen g6 move I think
actually I really like what Maxime did
in the last few moves so he can get
night to e3 well look at that night hop
in via f5 or d5 and there's no real way
for white to stop except from the Queen
a5 yep
but your Queens kind of going into
no-man's land over there here comes 93
yeah although was that intentional it's
more than 10 July the 9th either no
giving up the d4 pawn with it
well now Knight c2 is a actually Knight
d5 and 92 both pretty deadly threats and
here comes the ambulance I think you
hear that that's for that rook on f6
hope you understand being sent to the
emergency room the point everybody's the
Brooke is sort of pin to another
defended Queen so 95 again the obvious
move is a
we're coming to see two awesome actually
you don't see geometry like this yeah
very strange it's one of the things
that's been kind of not a pattern you
see every day so I've been a little
skeptical of how he did it but the 97
move was really key yeah in the 93
covered everyone as well look at just
might see two played wait but well the
95 was better than I'd see - what's his
follow-up on Queen c3e one is covered so
queasy Oh Wesley maybe find something
even better but he's got the back rank
and there's no way to deal with it so
you have to Queenie a check first to
protect the bishop and then play King g1
but then you were to lose the be to pawn
and that was a move dude rook e1 was
unexpected dude oh you know what it does
anymore oh my gosh that was awesome okay
draw anyway right because you talk about
the outside pawns earlier yeah here I
have an eight-part say watching it in a
draw anyway because I was worried that
white has perpetual check options so 10
seconds he's up on yeah you're you're up
a minute
you're up upon no choice find a way to
play this game on okay and so makes the
smart decision I think isn't begging for
a perpetual yet the best thing here
comes a five yeah me like an only black
can be better here yeah where is whites
perpetual I don't see it the Queen
centralized here guards all the squares
all the entry points the only question
is can you maintain that and advance
you're a pawn in these positions
everyone and that's kind of what they
pause to think about here is how do I
get my queen in a spot that lets me rush
but keeps the perpetual away yeah and
and look at this by the way sometimes
you get the perpetual way by just
bringing the king up oh my gosh
the Kenyan take that pond give me that
pond Queen d4 there's a trick
what's the trick I'm looking maybe it's
Queen e6 I don't know there's a queen e5
back Wow
what's this down a sidewalk here and
down on the board clear pawn now this is
the momentum you have to get if you are
the Frenchman with three names one win
at a time as Robert said move to come
back to e5 look at that looking at five
and sneak back to g6 yeah it's like I
served my purpose
I brought the king up I've won you're
deep on this is also good because again
we highlight this a lot in these Queen
upon endings right Robert that you have
to be willing to activate your King and
go into the face of checks in order to
win these end games often there's so
many checks here that I'm a bit
concerned you think he went too far I
just like putting my keen on g6 where I
knew it was safe but I think I think the
geometry will work here I think if you
can find a way so he goes c4 instead but
King before will happen and eventually
the point is you're gonna start blocking
checks and rush the a pawn yeah that's
true you can always block the Queen King
ace during the Queen B for if necessary
but but f6 Queen e3 I care let's put the
pawns are more about the check but
you're right f6 actually falling there
is pretty bad King bee to now no more
let's check on e 2 V 2 Queen e2 King C
free I think he's trying to okay goes to
a3 we hit king c1 and there are no more
checks cuz if you check in the back rank
I offer the Queen Trey he should have
gone then - B - yeah go for it go back
if you got to repeat three times Queen
but you see what I'm saying about how he
could have gone cooking to g6 and I
haven't dealt with all this yep it might
work out oh and Queenie 125 game on 21
25 trades Queen's out population so he
loses two games in a row sort of right
he's lost two of his last three mexicoís
Sheila Grove has made this a five point
match and we have lift-off ladies and
gentlemen because again even our smart
chess predictions said that Maxine Bosch
a the Grove is the favorite in Bullitt
now they correctly predicted Wesley so
was the favorite in blitz but this is uh
now remember Wesley not Wesley sorry m
vo was down four games against Wei Yi
and came back he did and now he's on
five here was just okay that's a ton
yeah but he has a bit of momentum he's
got some wind in his sails I don't know
if you saw it Danny but Wes he grabbed
his head he was not very happy yeah
about losing that end game just now and
so we say that Wes it really doesn't
tilt and that tends to be the case yeah
but is the first time for everything
and so Wesley needs to keep his
composure here he is playing quite well
overall he's up five games in this match
so it's not the time to you know
criticize yourself too harshly or to be
that guy it doesn't matter I'm up just
just play the ball that's it
diamond remember Ben Sylvan in the chess
TV Chet says good job showing emotion
Robert it almost looked real when you
freaked out people have often said that
you are a robot because you're so good
at chess that's really why I think it's
because you're the you're the funny man
and I'm just the guy who's always
[Laughter]
position slightly better no risk he's
doing good he's on he's on it got a
little bit of going a little bit of
going alright so if you take with the a
pawn you play a three yeah you're not
sure if I put a three a four but this B
five configuration for black it's not
going anywhere I think until you settle
on a three there instead of a four is
you you still believe in your Kings side
play here right you believe in Knight f5
and that kind of stuff so you're like I
don't need to be creating unnecessary
play over here right yeah OC 4 he's also
nice the square for the other night so
that a five can be ganged up on
he's also creating a two-on-one and the
a and B five right so that it's so
instructive
in certain endgame is a pushing these
pawns up the board and crit outside past
pauses and very very essential to all
this is that Knights are very bad
defenders against passed pawns they're
not blockading them so in certain
variations you know very far down the
road well bring up the analysis board so
I can show what you're the point
everyone Robert is highlighting c4
really regards how you take even though
it's technically two on two it's really
a two on one if you look at it from the
A to B file and that creates a dynamic
where White has this outside passed pawn
potential and it's Robert said Knight
end games are the closest to King and
pawn endings so they're just not the bet
they're not the fastest piece right
there kind of slow and clunky and so
whoever gets a passed pawn first often
and end games of King and knight or King
and pawn usually as much better may be
winning right that was great and well
now he pushes upon a c5 so out goes all
those points no no it's still there in
the sense that the Knights are weak
because he has Knight f5 96 to hit b7 so
I think that I think it Maxime is still
kind of in the driver's seat here well
there's no pawn be seven more well not
anymore I mean he played that right as I
highlighted it no but he defended it
well it was a good idea by Maxine with
c4 but Wesley found a way to kind of to
deal with the bike right in the
night-sun d6 1.57 watch for black is
that the ninety six plays on both sides
of the board hit 7 NB 5 and blacks
knights are really only playing on the
kingside so can't all queenie force by
95 check you can't if Queen e4 Knight g5
check Forks ville boomtown so here's the
by the way it works even if you take
with the knight right because you could
take exactly okay you get piece but
you're winning a pawn but Knight and as
you said Knight and games are closest to
King and pawn in games right and so
Knight and three verses Knight and too
often is just winning from the side the
extra pawn because of how similar they
are the pop king upon you
Hakkar Nakamura hanging out in the chat
called this whole night at 5d6 plan a
few moments ago and it came to a canid
reality yeah I mean this is max Eames
opportunity here by the way again look
at the clock
that's a momentum shifting here right
that's the second pawn that was just
lost a second pawn could be a second
game in a row here for MVP three and a
half out of four for MBO and this is
desperation by Wesley he's trying to get
an attack where one doesn't exist denied
enough for is hanging in the pink team
the Queen on d7 is hanging you can't
protect both well you can play tonight
eh five check I just go back to h2 I'm
very safe there
yeah and upon King h2 avoids the check
so if you go back I have well first of
all your Queens hanging so he just
resigns and we see those dancing heads
they might be moving a little bit closer
together here before the day is done
everyone watching yeah we see Wesley's
shaking a little bit there and he knows
that we got some momentum going there
you got it you got to stop the bleeding
now and he goes back this is Mexican
mercy LaGrande feet goes away from the
night off once again into this time mono
system and well we have this isolated
queen pawn again hopefully Maxime can do
more with it if you're a Maxime fan than
he did last game he ended up winning
that game in the between opponent game
but that you know it didn't look like it
should be winning for him after the
opening stage of the game I look like
white actually was the one with a an
advantage and in this particular game
this is only a French dear looks like a
bad French to bishops for white French
to bishops for white as we say in the
French let me play a dubious opening so
I can hope to grovel for equality for
the rest of my life that's that's the
motto right we see a diamond member over
there Award eagle saying bullet could be
interesting and bi want to come back and
for those confusing we're not rooting
for MVL neither is Hikaru I don't think
we just like close matches you know it's
nice sometimes when you see to the best
players in the world with a lot on the
line and a lot of games left so it's not
it's you know this is gonna be close and
I think that that's where the excitement
is coming from
yeah and for you know it looks like it'd
be a really just a lopsided matchup
because it was for the large majority of
this match but all of us
it's looking like Maxime is picking up
steam in 95 hits the between hits the
bishop yeah I was like wait did you miss
that it's is there I want there to be
Bishop h7 Queen h4 or h5 and then rook
d1 that's what I want so let's try it
this should be a submission page 7 King
takes Queen h5 you move rook 81 I mean I
doesn't that work okay yeah I wanted it
that might be getting it right Christmas
come early here rook a to d1 I think
although it doesn't really matter it
does matter he'll play 93 or 93
well 90 you just take with the Queen the
Queen you haven't solved the problem
right death okay yeah but 93 blocks the
D file and forces the ladies off the
board so it's nothing more than the
winner of a pawn but still an edge for
Wesley yeah but as we trade off the
pieces you go bishop somewhere rook c8
take over the only open file and this
should be yeah they're gonna they're
gonna agree in a draw because this is
the problem of the opposite colored
bishops maybe up a pawn as white but the
real issue is creating a clean pass pawn
as the LightSquared Bishop can block aid
in whatever pawn is trying to push
through a light square and the dark
square Bishop can't help that's progress
yep so okay well likely we see a draw
here but still Wesley so has not won in
about a half an hour and that's saying
something given that he was at one point
up what was the biggest lead seven or
eight games was it eight right he thinks
seven was the matter okay he's up he's
up four games right now but again if
you're just getting getting here it was
all Wesley so for the first 90 minutes
right now max team Bosh they the Grove
not only enjoying the taste of his
sweater but also the taste of his chest
right now
there you go and look at Maxime just
lock up the entire position put upon a
four submit the Queen side and the pawns
are on light squares so that the bishop
on d5 can go protect them at any moment
and the bishop when I 14 ever attack
it's just very very thematic
so now now what's interesting is this is
who's playing this one out is Maxime
trying to draw it out to get time off of
that 14 minute clock right there to try
to get to bullet but I don't think
that's a good strategy because I haven't
seen a drug offered and well with the
extra pawn Wesley is the one when the
time comes if he wants to offer a draw
it should only be right I guess that's
who's offering but I think we will see
that from that point it makes sense for
Wesley to draw it out because even if he
doesn't like his chances of bullet he's
still up for a game so you know give
what give max seemed less chances to
make a comeback and I saw her card
Nakamura in chat and I wonder what he
thinks about Maxine's chances what
deficit ins you need to reach in order
to have a very realistic shot at coming
back how much better of a bullet player
does he see Maxine being because well
Wesley has put a very good bullet
performance as well sound like he's oh
yeah a pushover of course so ancient
here is we see Li Ches saying who said
this was over let's go n VL we got
multiple chat rooms no matter where
you're tuning in from we see you thanks
for being here with Ches TV and and all
right now I'm convinced that so has got
a little bit of gamesmanship going on
here a little bit of let me let me
tickle this one out for a little while
and I got some time off that clock get
myself closer to bullet protect my lead
it just makes me love the speeches
championship that we have so many angles
to discuss here you have the time
ticking down which is unlike classical
chest you have this you know like we say
the meta the strategy the gamesmanship
what are they thinking about what format
do they like themselves in the angles
that we're gonna discuss a bit
orthogonal or not they're not orthogonal
but the rooks are operating on
orthogonal angles whoa wait f5 just
happened he's got d5 following devious
mists that he might have dude if these
things happen
okay seven you take the g7 yeah I just
Wesley's like uh is that a deep bone or
you're just happy to see me
wait but the HPI pond is on the light
square which means that I can probably
yeah no no but then the King and Bishop
are fighting for the squares right how
did you how to coordinate you need King
here and the bishop here Wow whoa okay
we'll back up in a second and see the
blunder cuz we lost your focus but now
me ain't nobody you can still
never never fully coordinated come
around to c5 b6 e 7 news ah this was
nice
now he can take just in time if you take
a trauma just take b5 no it takes the h5
you actually still have d7 you're just
winning oh yeah that's the problem
he's gonna win this oh my god what a
swindle this is unreal next f5 holy
jesus naps let's show everybody what
happened there that's unreal
first of all on real and you can't
really blame us we're here to entertain
all of you and we assumed it was a draw
- just like Maxime did again that's what
happens when you make assumptions look
at this you're moving all around ops
code bishops look but don't touch title
of the latest Kardashian autobiography
you move around but then we get a sack
of f5 forcing the D pawn through taking
advantage of the tactic but you can't
undefended and just like that white gets
a pass D pawn and black is frozen
because if he ever loses g7 we have a
second passer Wow oh my gosh what what a
swindle what a victory by Wesley so I
mean I think now that we're
reconsidering that last game Wesley was
very smart to keep playing he had no
risk whatsoever yeah and Maxime didn't
have much of a risk but that's the
problem when you start playing just you
know yours playing moves not really
thinking because it should be a draw and
then you make one careless decision and
I'm just like that's that's super
frustrating right I mean now the
question is so it was a clearly a
careless decision by Maxime there but
was it did he have to allow it anyway no
I guess he could have easily kept the
bishop on the proper
there would have been no trick yeah just
don't leave your Bishop on a square that
the king is attacking yep
where the it can be undermined but but
again it does it does give us a cool
take away shows you how come how many
hidden resources can exist in those
positions and again as you said why
Wesley still had every right to play on
yeah and this game right now we see that
if you take with the Queen on c5 you
hang the h6 bond so you probably don't
want to do that if you take with the
b-pawn you have split pawns on the Queen
side which it's not the end of the world
but pawns like to be connected to each
other so they can protect one another
and be take c5 here black has some
counter played on the B file denied
would get the d5 square instead he goes
for the more active approach but just
rip d8 rook deed Queen a6 looks like
it's yeah and I was highlighting that
he's got a already got a three-on-two so
if he can steal a 6 ok well Maxime
despite how painful that last loss has
to be in it it's gonna sting if he keeps
this within 4 games we have 9 minutes
left
it's possible this could be our last 3
minute game with increment how long it
goes most likely we have one more
3-minute game and Maxime I think is
gonna win look at this nice technique
here he forces the ladies off the board
the reason is now the F pawn was on pin
so you had to trade and here comes B for
a 5 and I think Maxime wins is hanging
yeah put that on c4 hit to b6 bump like
before a 5 is mentioned and again it's
about the often the quality of your
pawns name the quani I'm not going to
give you my c3 pawn so I work a three
first work a three also turns for e3 to
hit the on what you can also play f3
first if you want here I think that
might be even better
I have three yep let me yeah you can't
go to detour d6 if you go to c5 I gain a
tempo so max team taking a second but f3
and here comes the past pawn we've been
talking about there it is and Knight
takes e4 is possible because of the
rookie for b5 but it will go scoop up
the Pawnee with everything ok 5 would be
5 to take the pawn to c4 these masters
aren't clear that's the thing is right
it seems like black is a 4 on 2 on the
the e3 H files it's true but they're not
Pat's it takes a while to actually
question together and there will not be
- passed pawns together why would never
allow that so read this position now
where were ya questions do you forget
about just making a passer and try to
sync b6 as a weakness like B 5 and then
you're trying for rook D 6 and kind of
stuff but but yeah I was kind of
speaking generally regardless but yeah I
mean that was a concrete threat and now
whoa dude he did that without even like
I don't think he actually calculate I
mean this work I mean if it doesn't
brilliant if it does it's brilliant if
it doesn't it's still brilliant just not
my favorite kind of brilliant the great
thing is the Nanji fund covers the be so
dominant and now the problem is though
the rook is so perfect here prevents the
pawns from advancing and keeps the King
at bay so black is trying to create pass
pawn or yeah so waiting now and white is
trying to rush the King over to be - and
kick that rook from behind the pot at
some point you're gonna be just all in
here with black trying to calculate
whether you can take g2 and make Harry a
real wizard over here before we get a
queen on a8 so strange
Jinxy - is he okay - check you've got to
think about it now you've got a minute
you're gonna use 30 seconds here I think
you got everybody deep as you can
nope wrong so wait now King all right so
now the courses king b2 a Knight c3
Mason cuts your work off all right so
Knight c3 actually my trapping you're
too noisy threes wouldn't move these it
you do a rook e1 I guess 8th it's a fork
for the King demon and my King runs Team
B 7 B 5 okay Kings c8 I think is
probably move King bees with b6 now
beefcakes b7 b6 if rook takes b7 you
can't stop the pond b6 King c6 then I
snow b7
7b 657 deposit is too fast dude oh my
gosh Maxime is converting he's gonna
keep this thing closed the car 94 gives
it lol so bad Wesley but either way
we're gonna have a four-game lead once
again for the American and one more 3
minute game on the agenda before full of
commences oh my gosh what a turn of
events
first Maxime Bosh's the position for
this you know in a drawn position now
he's getting snatching a victory from
the jaws of a draw crazy though because
I mean Maxime was the heavy underdog in
the 3-1 portion again if you missed the
stats earlier Wesley so has performed
pretty much higher than everybody in the
3-1 portion historically including a
match where he got routed by magnus
carlsen he actually won the three
minutes segment so this would be an
interesting turn of events if if Maxime
takes the three-minute segment here he's
already up for three you can see the
scoreboard there below their names yep
and you're just making use of those
pawns right now you wonder something
that's funny well I think Maxime is
wearing the same sweater of his little
avatar there next to Leon Beast I think
it's very the same sweater from the
avatar okay he's pulling away with his
face should he should find a way for
these two pawns to make it happen now
you can even play b7 with tempo you can
also play 93 to try to go to c5 to block
the checks yep where's he going
b7 chunk is devastating he's gonna after
check again he's gonna just run run away
I guess yeah there's no way to deal with
b7 Wow one last game one last
three-minute game possibly two if we see
a blunder in the next two or three
minutes but most likely this is our
final three one game after this we will
have bullet and there will be blood
in bullet I mean
metaphorically speaking yeah that
sounded very just on see deadly honestly
it's not like a movie yes there will be
blood
yeah is that like a Daniel day-lewis
flick yeah is it you you you're asking
it as if you don't know I kind of know
but I kind of don't I was kind of making
sure you 100% know that movie you've
probably seen it you are a Daniel
day-lewis fan so I have I speak I speak
last of Mohicans what some say I wasn't
Mohican in my past life but okay that's
another story but for sure I can't stand
you right now gangs in New York what's
your favorite thing that they Lewis
filmed now that Louis my left foot was
really really good I could look at this
that's why you don't go movie buff with
Robert I like the movie about the in the
name of the Father
okay that was good that was little slow
for me honestly but alright really yeah
okay chest and onions in the chest TV
says karo can't a meals actually played
well since he switched away from the
Sicilian into the carro cons and other
thing or let's say it's gone better than
his Sicilian house today car saying we
have such bad taste in movies I mean I'm
not I'm not really looking at car for
last of Mohicans I know he does but that
movie was so long all right back to the
chest
so right now White has an extra pawn in
the center but black has an advanced age
poem which seems strange when you've
Castle kingside and your senior pawn in
front of your king but this is actually
very thematic it's a topical line that
black has enjoyed quite a good deal of
success with in many top-level games
let's go to the analysis board just to
show that because on nine Queen to c2
that's kind of where the topical
variation begins as Roberts suggested
the point is 85 while odd when the king
is Castle you've got certain other
dynamics here like the open lines
or the kingside that kind of justify
this advance and so black always in this
weird kind of structure has outside
chances of kind of a King side attack
and h4 again T matically almost alpha
zero ish esque pushing those pawns oh
and now he just won the what happened
here did so just blundered the the pawn
with Bishop takes e5 he did wow you know
he's maxime up upon ops got bishops
welcome back my old friends max even
he's really been dominating this time
saying he has and it'll be the last game
here officially so if he gets another
victory and we move into three game
territory it's not to say so still not
the favorite at this point three games I
didn't you know if you had asked him
he'd probably take that but given that
he was up by eight by seven okay I'm
sorry seven but still seven seven point
lead is just seemingly insurmountable
but right now Maxime is making the
comeback and let's talk about this
position here again because it's
opposite colored bishops we saw Maxime
trying to defend a pawn down obstacle a
bishop position two games ago and now
he's a pawn up and the way that black
tries to play for win is creating
weaknesses on both sides the boy yep big
negative about the position for black is
that you've these double pots and why is
that such a bad thing it's hard to
create a past one you've doubled pawns
but you have all the time in the world
as long as you don't trade off all the
rooks you don't want to trade off both
pairs you might get to have one pair but
then you want to start moving your King
up into the action maybe he's in with
his second pawn to f6 I'll try to go to
b5 things of that but now rook T for Kim
because the a5 pawn look at that Dan
yeah that's a nice defensive idea by so
in fact I think he got out of this
already that might have been to move the
kind of secures I'm gonna hold this
thing you were doing a great job
highlighting and I do think moving the F
pawn and bringing the King up you know
Black has this sort of four-on-three
advantage and now no longer doubled but
a five I don't think Mac seems gonna
give up I think he's still gonna try
from when I like f6 maybe even king of
seven I was gonna say g5h four you can
guard b7 with the rook but you can still
make some progress over here on the
Kings side
yeah oh yeah I guess you're right there
are some chances there he's going for it
because he has to play on this is the
last game yeah well right you got to try
to win and we saw Wesley so swindle him
in an obstacle Bishop bending and maybe
he wants to return the favor
also these positions make me think of
vintage gothic comps
yeah because that was the type of player
who would get this position you'd say
pretty much 99.9% of players we just
make a draw and gotta just make your
life is difficult possible move by
moving here for example us because
they're at 4-4 block because even if I
give up a pawn if I can dislodge your
Bishop from e3 square and start pushing
my pawn up the board that is going to be
no F for right you get split pawns you
can take h4 oh that looks good I like it
f4 it wasn't baby split them baby yeah
that's what I'm talking about put the
King on f5 and swing the rook over it
goes to show that max you didn't playing
better and mutual time trouble and just
one time yep
starts taking it seems like Maxime is
the one who is actually King h5 here
also very plausible in fact eh v g7 g3
is weird things where you almost want to
tempt him to take the pawn and then made
him but yeah you you wouldn't mean I got
made on the brain you know it king of
five then you can play Bishop e6 and try
to eventually punch him out some sort of
check yeah oh he goes B should be six
right away he wants the whole thing but
that means okay you still gotta defend
the pawn so it's kind of the same
position I wanted that King might land
on f3 if you're not careful oh dude
that's the idea
it's king g4 you give up the pawn you
gain a tempo and then king of three I'm
not giving up the pawn I mean you you
can give me one at all you want Bishop
d5 and then kimchi for I want everything
today
great great director by the way fellow
phenomenal first novel should we talk
about our favorite game weirdo terminal
del Toro films are known for those as
well
only if after we get to talk about our
favorite Benicio del
horror films then I'll do okay okay
later
wait is that Bishop trapped wait rook
each one
oh shoot rich wardens gonna end the
games Bishop engage one at the e3
check-in Wesley so as long as he's lost
his first ever 3-1 segment in the speed
chess championship yeah by a score of
three games
that's the comeback that Mexi meet it
he's now only down three points heading
into the bullet portion and Danny we
thought this match might be over with
yeah we're told in the past never to
call a match over until it's over that's
right well it clearly is not over in
Joshua Chamberlain strikes again we have
a match here Maxine Vashti the grog was
favored and bullet by almost two games
so don't go anywhere buckle up the 2019
speed chess championship quarter-final
continues in just a few minutes and we
are back with the 2019 speech as
championship the action is hot hot fire
will it be Wesley so on fire here
finding himself in the bullet stopping
the bleeding so to speak as Maxine voce
the Grob mounts an epic comeback or will
the predictions that nvl will be better
when the fastest portion begins hold
true Robert your thoughts and what
you're feeling here make a prediction
for us well we've touted that Wesley so
doesn't get tilted but unfortunately for
him right now he has gone -4 since being
up seven points in this matchup I'm a
bit nervous friend he knows that he's
the underdog in the bullet portion I
would not say he is a three point
underdog right in that time segment so
he has to be he's favored if we were
putting odds on it but projections don't
take into account human emotion right it
doesn't take it accounts some potential
tilts back there I think Wesley can hold
on to this I do think he can I do think
he will but max team is not going to
make his life easy it's gonna be
exciting
Maxine photograph won't make his life
easy and bullet and he won't make his
opponents lives easy in the first ever
puzzle battle of World Chess
Championship that is coming up what I
can't confirm for you right now as we
all get set for the announcements were
about to make I've been making teasers
about this event
but MBL has committed to play all he
reza firoozeh has committed to play Rhea
Robson also known as the spicy
caterpillar the legend has committed to
play we are working on other top players
I expect more announcements soon but
it's going to be exciting it's going to
be a combination of puzzle rush and
puzzle battle our two most popular
features frankly here and watch out for
chest column / news is we've released
all the details anybody in the world can
try to qualify for this event
qualification opens up and begins on
November 22nd people will have to submit
themselves achieving certain records at
puzzle rush on video partly for the
legitimate the legitimacy of your of
your candidacy to be qualified and where
it goes from there we will let you know
more details soon but get ready the
puzzle battle volts this chain feel
coming your way right now we need to get
ready for bullet and the game's shouts
begin here we go bullet
we've got Grand Master Robert has
hanging on the chest TV chat I see you
over there baby
let's see you let's see you rocket I'm
getting involved I want people you know
to know that I appreciate them we got we
got chatters everywhere no matter where
you're tuning in from thanks for being
here
we've had as many as almost 15,000 of
you watching at one point today in
English and still looks like to be about
12,000 of you with us the bullet is on
if anybody left earlier thinking this
was gonna be a landslide well shame on
them because we have excitement we Evans
gambit of all things and start off the
bullet western jacket he's he's in for a
fight right now but if you look at this
with d5 isn't when the oh there's no
quitting for checkers you've seasick
just like that so Oh Knight g5 though
this is nice if you Castle there's queen
h5 yep of seven here taken f7 you just
guide takes up seven you got to go for
lolly gambit this bleep up this is fried
liver material knighting of seven queen
h5 King e6 rookie 100 or even queen of
three first but the point isn't in five
is falling yep because there was no
rookie one sad because the fish 185 was
holding it's where but here you won defy
the king is going to be in harm's way
does the actually know we're good for
that King to go should a three check his
Queenie for three check might have been
better this is one of those if this ends
up being a consistent feature by Maxime
I wonder if he prepared anything special
for bullet to really try to take Wesley
by surprise yeah we'll have to ask him
because it looks like it's panning out
right now that's a 98 why skiing is so
safe over there and we'll take on d4
would be a disaster for black now you
open up the D file and the King is on
that file qui-gon Bishop g5 and you King
got a run you know King sees a queen
I've got to get out king c8 King b8
cross your fingers also 20 extra 25
extra seconds for Maxine Maxine this is
why people thought the bullet would be
the toughest challenge for Wesley and
right now he needs to speed up look at
him take the pond I don't give her works
laughs in the face of danger Simba well
I don't know what kind of laughing
you're doing but I think Maxime is
thrilled that that pawn was captured
opens up the D file now you can take on
b7 you can see got c7 d4 is gonna be
hanging in some of these lines well
remember didn't go well for simple for a
long time so yeah yeah well he was he
was forced to run away by his talked
about the problem is the knight is
pinned and there's not a lot to do about
any only three seconds and playing a
position with the King on d8 not your
favorite thing that wins a piece and
guess what the comeback is on maxtv the
Robins going to take the first bullet
game Wesley trying to play this one out
a little bit I think trying to shake off
some nerves but also from a practical
point of view the longer the games last
the better yeah they take some time off
the mesh cloth right and just what's how
much times the 27 minutes yeah if he can
write himself at some point soon and
just get a win here and there and still
to game lead for Wesley its yeah it's
gonna be real tough and by the way this
this got a little bit harder for Maxine
than he would have liked
yes Kate still completely winning but
the point is Wesley if he was trying to
take another minute off the total clock
he did so
and how many pawns are you gonna lose
the press it doesn't matter he doesn't
mean he's been lost here forever so I
just what I what I like is the
gamesmanship I like the the attitude
honestly and he's been playing with one
second fight with one second on the
increment literally and he's freezing
over I mean what is Maxime gonna push
the a pawn he's not he's gonna push the
h-bond instead there goes next G pawn
alright finally he's getting all his
pawns go okay this should be enough you
seem convinced
Wesley's gonna play it out to checkmate
because why not again he just took a
whole nother minute off the clock he's
got a three game lead to protect he
knows he's down I mean he knows he's
he's the underdog and the bullet portion
and so Mac seems gonna have to prove it
if he wants that comeback though he's
smiling while he was getting checkmated
so you know was he's always a good sport
and he's doing the right thing right in
terms of gamesmanship you're the one who
generally highlights this point but if
you are up two games and you're kind of
insecure about your bullet skills here
and look Weez doing this game trade off
Queens getting into a position that
should be slightly better for white
generally speaking and with the theory
behind him minimal or less risk than
some other variations but of course it's
bullet anything can happen blunders to
occur but I like Wesley's strategy thus
far of course needs to stop losing games
that's essential I see been fine well
I'm gonna play devil's advocate to that
I mean psychologically you're kind of I
mean okay I guess the math probably
checks out that regardless of
psychological weaknesses you should take
time off the clock protect your lead but
it feels like you're really submitting
to the fact that you're the worst bullet
player when you do something like that
yeah but I think there's a difference or
a distinction I should say between being
defeatist
and being realistic I'm I think Wesley
is the worst bullet player right but
he's not giving up hope in the bullet
and well I mean if we want to talk about
bullet for a second look at maxim's time
you spent two seconds for the entire
game obviously he's been getting time
back with the increment but was he is
on here and so it's a position that was
to be extremely frustrated if he ends up
losing this game because yes up a pond
he has been it seemed like a safe
position but now his things open up for
the bishops night so we got a night move
90 was good this looks good just work
take it Maxime Nate that's what that's
what I'm thinking in the psychology here
I feel like that's that's almost
submitting I'm gonna be worse every game
I need to get clock I need to get the
clock down but there's plenty of time
for Maxime to come back like you've got
to like you have got to buckle up and
know that you're you still gotta win
this thing on the board if you're gonna
win the match because that two-game lead
will go away in 24 minutes it's going
right now right I mean one game let's
remind everybody real quick about the
daily question just because it probably
plays a little bit of a part here we
said that Wesley so it'll it is now 1:30
a.m. for him in India and Maxime of
course playing in his regular time zone
so you know it is a difficult thing bus
Lee's literally playing this match
before the Calcutta rapid and blitz
begins there that for the Grantchester
or hick or Nakamura there along with
many others but it's not over yet and
he's played fantastic chess all day I
don't think Wesley would use time as an
excuse but but if you get tired Robert I
mean that's that's a big deal you got to
be able to manage those situations here
yeah though it's one of those things
where obviously the players knew about
this match pretty far in advance right
so you should adjust in prepare for it
accordingly and they did and you know
I'm not trying to criticize either play
yeah and it is very fair to wonder if
playing at 1:30 in the morning or
whatever time it is right now yep in
India is working against him it likely
is but there's only so much you can do
right yep yeah to be fair yesterday I
mean obviously ding was tired too even
though you know those who work in
organizing these things know that ding
actually suggested that match time for
him so it was like one of those things
where it's very hard these guys are very
busy and they love playing chess online
but you know it's certainly something
that's interesting maybe maybe guys who
pull long late night owl' hours have
some kind of advantage in these formats
yeah and I kind of bodes well for a
player like Maxime I would think more
than it does
Yesi right now he's just playing
incredibly well he's about to get
another victory and the the comeback is
on only one second for so but look at
this look at this pawned by the way H
pawn h1 doesn't match the bishop
some outside chances but no the king is
coming in first very smart of ya no he
can't reach the square yeah if he was an
h1 it already means you can't reach the
square too slow if he had vishay one so
Wesley shakes his head he's trying to
pull himself together here we have a one
game lead with only 20 minutes left we
are gonna have fireworks here it's gonna
be close can't wait to see where this
one finishes and his match has really
turned around yep it's this is shocking
stuff for Wesley you need to just get
something you need to get half a point
somewhere yep and we highlight one of
the best things about his personality
typically is his is his calm demeanor
very level-headed very objective and
technical and accurate and his approach
to the game and kind of off the board -
but everybody's a human being and when
you lose a few games in a row even
someone like Wesley might be capable of
tilt so he's got he's got to stop the
bleeding now and someone like chess
Brainiac 13 is capable of asking for a
shout out with a please at the end so no
TV there you go chess Brainiac I see you
I've seen you throughout the match I
feel like Jeff Bray Nia has been asking
for me to shout him out in chess TV for
like months and I've refused and you've
literally just gave him what he wanted
well I'm also curious what's going on
with that fifth grade class still here
shout out to the fifth grade class - is
falling so do play rook d8 now or do you
take on d3 okay so I like that he's
building the tension because he was
saying if d4 happens everyone that the
light scores were dominated and he would
be in a great position for an attack so
he kind of forced Maxime to trade
instead of pushing and I think so has
has great chances here look out for
these light squares the bishop is the
wrong color yeah this is actually quite
for yep maxime here as well that queen
gets to d5 oh there it is
here comes Knights coming in to f3 maybe
rook chief 6 as well this looks looks
fantastic Wesley and by the way for the
first time all first time in Bullitt
well can I need to get a win that stole
my thunder I was gonna say for the first
time he's up on the clock maybe he'll
get a win and Maxime just resigns now
that's good man strategy the other way
we've been talking about so playing it
out protecting the lead everybody for
max seemed to have the experience
himself Robert to say hey you know what
at best I'm gonna grovel and maybe draw
this but take another three minutes off
the clock instead just resigned because
at this point what would you rank how
much is how much is a half a point worth
at this point with time like it's worth
I would say about two and a half minutes
right and so if he grovelled and gets
that draw but loses all that time like
it's not it doesn't matter anyway right
yeah so I'm just saying I like the match
strategy by Maxime to just throw in the
towel early but that was huge for Wesley
because for sure he put a really nice
game he end up winning look at this game
now he's white again we have a knight or
he is just dominating max seems neither
I mean I'm not even saying this is a
joke players might want to look at this
match and be like hey Maxine has scary
night or but it doesn't look so scary
gee three traps Bishop Bishop shows
about to stop the bleeding completely
maybe win his second game Wow just
picking that Bishop up you can't even
take on Age 3 because 95 comes in you're
going to checkmate it looks like oh here
comes 95 just give me everything just
take on h4 let's check first then take
h4 and if you take up one I'll take g7
oh you could have even taken g7 and I
know this is even better patient there's
you're not going anywhere
yeah he just resigned whoa Wesley so
strikes back pushes things to a three
game lead yet again look at this a
turnaround amazing scoreboard updated
wrongly we'll fix that everyone Maxime
has eleven and a half and Wesley has
fourteen and a half but yes
a huge victory there from Wesley so
keeps it keeps the the chances of
winning this thing alive doesn't let
Maxime ever get fully back in it to tie
the match and look this g5 moves
typically you don't want to push pawns
from York English so this several times
in the match today but what's his f6
palm protecting the pawn g58 limits the
man f3 it limits the bishop on D to
scope and so black is just taking over
space saying I'm going double my Brooks
the e-file perhaps and I could buy g4
right now and say where's your night
going in fact your night has to go to h4
it would you have surprised he didn't do
that actually
and still Jeep or no g4 the knight can
okay now h3 is place you can't go to g4
back to being a little patient here
which probably good now notice the time
max team has picked up his his tempo
here mm-hmm he's moving quickly he knows
well he's backs against the wall 17
minutes left about up and trying need to
get victories I drawers don't help him
at all he just sports consecutive wins
in the very near future so he's trading
pieces take takes may be Queen b3 hope
so he's gonna take before that's the
essential question does he does even the
dark squares though Knight g4 comes
Bishop takes e5 Bishop c5 is open for
business
Wesley missed that I mean I was looking
at the King on f7 things right but then
there's a 95 score so
Bishop takes g5 steals that pawn and
with it if he's too in the game because
98 speaks of six keep taking where the
protection that you 5 is dropped and now
just take everything take g7 even trade
it all like Queen f3 if you wanted to be
safe than sorry we don't get the ladies
off the board don't let there be
anything nasty on the h-file
yeah very nice I like it yeah if you
start doing the math here everyone every
game is super important because with
three minutes sorry three game lead 15
minutes on the clock and Beale totally
within striking distance but you start
to really watch the clock as far as
evaluating his chances ooh
95 check but still the knight protects
the c6 square
and Mexican right we know Wesley
strategy right what's the strategy is to
play every single game mountains will
checkmate to waste as much time on the
game clock as papa
that's smart right yep it just it's a
logical thing to do yep and okay Maxime
made very quick work of that one brings
it back within two games shout-out to
Grandmaster Kaden trove hanging out in
the chest TV chat and everybody over
there cadence played one of these
matches long ago before there was the
speech Chess Championship I haven't
heard the name Kaden truck in a really
long time yeah hang it out in chess TV
Kaden practically grew up on chess comm
so well worked out in a newspaper I
became a grandmaster and crazy what do
you think about this Sicilian Danny
different style what is this this is a
hybrid of everything it's a drag adora
Bennigan's with the knight on c6 the
classical Sicilian this is so crazy you
you like crazy now I do like crazy I
mean again I like white I just like I
did in the dragon Dorf and here it's
easy for me to say that everyone's the
plump okay but here comes back again
with cop 94 I like black we're changing
our Tunes here so just like Queen b7
okay takes it that I didn't love so much
yeah but e 7 was hanging so I mean V 3
so really kind of taken his time here to
get that King out of the center makes me
nervous
well he's trying to place c4 which just
shuts down that Bishop Queen if I check
the bishop D to hear them play C 4 after
Queen e7 c4 is number 93 check very nice
d4 93 and if you Castle now you have
maybe have time to take advantage of the
pin or do you h5 yeah I'm looking I'm
looking looking to get a victory here if
I'm so I mean this is looking better for
white but I like the practical decisions
by max team just now to sacrifice the
piece because there are there is hope to
survive the problem is it's going to
take a lot of time off the clock right
however he's only down two games yeah he
can avoid losing this one
yep and just make somehow hold his
endgame then he's still in the match but
if he loses this and spends time loose
you know this is now it's now draw or go
home for Maxime kind of right you have
to keep this a two game you have to keep
this at your game store now that's not
totally true for those of you wondering
I think the biggest comeback we ever
have with with a little amount of time
was young Chris of Duda last year was
down two games with six minutes left and
beat grew shook and it didn't even
matter it didn't even need overtime
right you remember that that was like it
was the buzzer beater yeah buzzer beater
so so the the biggest comeback we've
ever seen with little time was two games
by Duda with six minutes to remain in
last year's SCC you think he should have
resigned this game because right now
it's looking it's it's getting I mean
you're getting in that territory where
you either need to resign with 12
minutes or you better hope you can draw
Oh meeting that 9006 regime 809 65 stole
upon and stopped to me yeah that's nice
and now night see 76 actually okay I'm
taking back my words as I was saying
maybe you should have thrown the towel
but so simple yet because if you move
the night I will get Knight f6 okay f5
that's nice
wow what a move he's gonna force the
rook and Bishop versus rook endgame but
look at so he wants more he didn't trade
everything on f6 yeah but if he takes an
f6 I'm scared of that pawn now yeah
that's a dangerous pawn you bring that
bishop in and it's made on the back rank
yeah okay but how do you get the king of
oh look at this working it now be 55 oh
we missed it d function whence the brook
oh my gosh
that's huge oh that was not the kind of
loss you want because too much time went
away with it he still has time to catch
up and still us minutes so it's not but
he's just in that critical territory of
hey I really wish I had resigned to
happen this earlier yeah yeah and it's
hard because you don't want to resign to
now minutes early you felt like you had
a chance but then it crossed that
territory where he was almost pot
committed he had to try to see if he
could hold it right yes you know he
all in at that point eventually he was
all in so he just said I got to keep
playing I'm gonna go look at this he's
he's all in on this position this is
fantastic for white this is a great way
to come back from that loss make a
comeback bring it to within two games
again and you still give yourself we'll
call it a young Krista do to sense
did he blunder because Knight takes e5
Oh 97 check ow he like oops I thought
max teen blunder but it turns out it was
Wesley who ended up wondering even he's
got his hand he knows he needs to keep
the game going though because he has to
keep the time ticking away
I can't quit Wesley what it's like
playing down a queen because that never
happens for these guys yep so I'm very
curious to know like he's obviously very
upset and he keeps shaking his head in
his hands but it's pretty hilarious for
us to see Wesley so playing down to what
it's and again that he's clearly clearly
getting a little bit exhausted there but
you don't see them try to defend
positions like this so maybe they come
up with creative ideas that we don't
normally see every day this is awesome
down so completely dead look at Maxime
the technique rook takes c6 mate I loved
it I loved it so it's because he's like
well that didn't go well
that was impressive finding the quickest
checkmate like yeah that would know I'm
that's what I was you thought it was
kidding the technique was real dude that
was impressive yeah I mean because he
system of him losing that game and all
the time he just won that game and what
75 seconds that was pretty quick game
yeah but he he's proving that he's going
to be a force in the battle rush
championships because that was very
quick vision and you know from
experience and you make a great move
that's not the absolute best move and
you're like yep
wrong okay so let's see we have nine
minutes in the master clock which means
we have about four games maximum left if
he I guess was he's using all the time
the clock glory this is this is not the
kind of game Maxime wanted this is gonna
be a grind it
out almost your dare I say a to result
position for white already Robert oh
yeah this is just very pleasant for
white black isn't playing 97 9 to 5
intro to hold down the position but I
thought that was a poor opening choice
he almost would rather risk it you know
no risk get no biscuit in this sort of
line of work when the clock is tickin
away right so I mean doesn't need to go
for anything crazy night h3 hopefully
five butts but it's it's well sensitive
that g6 pawn and the position is very
close which means that even if Wesley
eventually lose this game I could see
this game taking four more minutes yeah
so closed okay but if you're Maxime and
you win just one more you're within a
game right you've got to get it got to
get it to one here yeah I think you just
you just cannot so even if he makes a
draw you need to do whatever he's gonna
do quickly yep and losing is clean
trapped I wasn't looking for it 96 will
out Queen a5 in the pond so I don't
think Mac seems too hot either I mean
that looks still very dangerous for
white but but now you might have to in
some positions not anymore
h4 s falling Oh take that take it take
it
although Knight f4 next and that rook is
kind of yeah but if you go native fourth
Queen fi Oh within g6 well I'm not
calculating I'm just suggesting moves
and that let's do the g6 pawns hanging
but maybe like I still okay there and
he's calculating it but he was queen d6
keeping in there in age three I think
this is smart Queen f5 can't be played
the g3 rook is not protected so just
play 96 I like it wow look at mix I mean
look at the credit he gets he's suddenly
he's the one pushing here yep a lot of
time coming off the clock but if he gets
I think he could get this win now
yet 964 was a threat which is why yeah
the battery on the e-file oh that's a
pawn stole one pawn here comes rookie -
oh gosh the second rank is blacksville
taking the king is not safe this is
coach maxium this is this is gonna get
to one game it's gonna come down to the
clock oh gosh so eight seconds for
Maxime okay no well take on it he missed
that outside pass bonus better though
White has two of them no no black is
definitely better here played g5 get
another outside pass pawn okay and I I
thought the connectors the connected
pastors would be good but you okay black
is too fast with hna yeah here comes the
King back or other night okay whatever
it brings the piece back and he's aged
and after two so the King on the Kings
side can't protect both pawns this is
crazy or yeah play King now King Drive
you can win all the pawns whoa what is
huge saved by Wesley Oh - quickly yeah
he just he just missed that fork trick
it's gonna be a draw that's brutal
what a save right there that's so brutal
Wesley just did him a favor by taking
that before letting the 13 seconds run
off he could have taken another 15
seconds away roughly and then taken the
pawn
that was such a well-played game by
maxium ya know he deserved that win but
Wesley steals stalemate and with it he
maintains a two-game lead with five
minutes left here oh man this is this is
why we do this right here yes that's the
tricky part about playing with a timer a
countdown because the card Nakamura the
best bullet player that we've seen
online here and you know well Magus
Magnus's can be in the debate but okay
we see a car playing regularly and those
moments where you have to spend an extra
half second you spend a full second and
with an increment you can afford to
spend that second but with the timer and
the countdown
what's him one to win that game as
pretty as possible much more important
than ten seconds was winning the game
and so he should have stopped at that
point it's easy for me to say you know
I'm not in this very tense environment
I'm just commentating on the games
and you need to stop and think about it
for just a split second more and he
would have won that game crazy yan
depandi on she says world champion at
his best referring to wesley self fisher
random world chess champion that's my
well yan knows the force of wesley of
wesley and Fisher random right well this
was good for Maxime again he has if he
could take that night it's a beautiful
dominant night against him but now
officially in must-win territory from
here on out and we're also in
positionally one position for white
right right no Maxime should win this
game but he has to it's now there
there's I mean we add drama sometimes
and and say it's must win or go home but
this is this is now it it's white
converts this game or Wesley so is
moving on at the semi-finals yep and
actually I think that White's advantage
is disappearing very quickly yeah that
was a nice way for so to close the beef
file with the bishop protecting the pawn
and Maxime is getting super defensive
here but no this is not I mean this is
not playing for win at all yep I think
he should have tried for some time the
King says in g4 at the right moment
because 95 yeah I feel like it was the
advantage was bigger in the middle game
that it is here but he can still play
for g4 not yet oh maybe yet but my point
essentially is if he goes g4 didn't you
try to play E for well now he definitely
can't do that after this trail event
look at snow by the way he's just he's
also correctly using his time here just
super impressive
now what's these better before saying
yeah I mean I said he escaped rookie
three forking the two pawns oh man the
question for Wesley is you just you just
keep playing right let's point you could
almost clinch the match right here with
the draw yeah a draw actually will
clinch the match see we just spend all
his time yep so Maxine this is a in need
of a miracle blunder or his speech his
championship is
gonna have to wait till next year and
with that he resigns I'm not sure he's
aware of the total time but that was
probably the wrong probably the wrong
decision h5 was that the right decision
I think now he knows he knows yes he's
not trolling unless he knows he
officially sees the match go away with
that loss and Wesley so we'll be heading
to the semi-finals crazy I really
thought Maxine was gonna get that win
there and bring it to one game I thought
so as well I mean he was on a tear it
looked like Wesley was in danger of just
collapsing but kudos to Wesley he hung
in there yeah he found a way to survive
that night endgame I mean that was just
unreal because that was Maxine's game
would have cut the deficit to one point
and said they draw Maxie must go all-in
the next give me losses a long battle
and ya know that draw swindle there
really saved the match right that was it
was a huge moment they're saving the
game and if you're just tuning in
looks like we we know who is moving on
mathematically it's pretty much certain
but we will still have interviews Wesley
so and Maxine vache the Grob will be
joining us we'll get both of their
thoughts on the X's and O's the
practical stuff that went down and of
course we'll get max Eames thoughts on
his biggest match the biggest match he's
ever had in his career which is tomorrow
now I almost feel like I have to let him
adopt me you know but I'm not gonna do
it I'm not gonna let him it's not gonna
happen Maxine I think he'd be very upset
if you let him life you must earn it it
should it should be consensual though if
it's gonna happen I mean honestly if I'm
gonna let the adoption happen it better
be a willing thing so just making sure
you understand that yeah I'm gonna again
it's gonna be a fun interview don't go
in to everybody yeah both these players
are super nice so you know despite the
fact that Maxine loses ultimately in the
SEC court file here
he's a good sport he'll give us some
good information and also yeah curiously
he won the three-minute and if he wins
this game he also wins the bullet
portions of it if you take away the fact
that he lost by six points in the launch
of seven games
it's hard to come back from that yes on
time with it we are out of time actually
in the bull I don't even realize it the
speech Chess Championship quarter-final
goes to the American by a final score of
17 to 15 there you have it this gave us
all we could handle I think despite the
tilt by Maxine Bosh a magrav earlier it
was a thriller Wesley so holds on we'll
be back with player interviews in just a
few minutes don't go anywhere we'll be
right back
miss that fork trick it's gonna be a
draw that's brutal
what a save right there that's so brutal
Wesley just did him a favor by taking
that before letting the 13 seconds run
off he could have taken another 15
seconds away roughly and then taken the
pawn it was such a well-played
[Music]
a Premium Membership at chess calm will
help you improve your game with full
access to a powerful set of learning
tools unlimited tactics let you practice
like a master with more than 50,000
puzzles to challenge you at every level
our library of interactive chess lessons
created by master coaches will enhance
every aspect of your game and after each
game you play the computer analysis
feature will give you feedback on every
move you played turning every game into
a chance to learn and that's not all
premium benefits also include unlimited
tournaments video lessons the opening
Explorer and much much more upgrade now
to take your game to the next level and
we are now joined by our competitors
here for today's speech s Championship
quarter-final grandmasters vache magrav
and so gave us quite the thriller today
maxime with the most important match of
your career looming less than 24 hours
from now you will have a match that will
maybe define you as a chess player today
[Music]
because we couldn't get at the same time
quality by our standards and tilapia I
made it too much of my dreadful stocks
but obviously starting with kind of a
funny question for those who don't know
Maxime and I having a fun match tomorrow
but I mean we have lots of serious chess
questions ahead and I the truth is you
you almost did give us what would have
been for sure the greatest comeback ever
in Sec history statistically you trailed
at one point by seven games and how how
nervous were you Wesley as Maxime was
kind of mounting his comeback
and given given you a scarier in the
bullet obviously I thought standard Oh
for this much else so you know Maxime
it's one of the best place in the world
in bits and also right now is number one
in the world in racket so the other than
iterating is not the secrets to win this
to a minute so the start in the five
minute was obviously surprising I
couldn't imagine that without any I mean
to be honest I thought before the match
I have to be leading before the bullet
section because simply I think my team
is much faster than me in bullet as is
clear in the match and before to put it
hours actually leading by three but then
I think I was my first game just my
first two bullets or just one your first
one yeah I think I was losing also in
the second round so things didn't seem
prepared by the third point but somehow
things change and thank me a consultant
yeah I think at some point I was being
damaged by one or two points for that
was obviously critical and in the end I
was basically Saved by the Bell and one
same Randolph is fine yeah
Maxime I have a question for you about
the five-minute portion of course the
result didn't go your way but more of
question by your openings you kind of
went away from your traditional night
orth early on it was that specific
preparation against Wesley or did you
just feel like mixing up your repertoire
for today's match yeah I really didn't
have any opening preparation sorted out
for today and I have work to do but
[Music]
another tournament in Jerusalem so I
didn't reparent
when it was is at my night off wouldn't
make it
at least for the 5+1 games I started to
deviate everywhere codes maxime help how
tough is that were the you know when the
losses start happening and we know that
tilt can happen in this match format you
played in as many speeches Championships
as anybody but what is the what is the
take away after that when you know that
you came so close to winning this match
ultimately mounting a very impressive
comeback but if you had just a couple
games back in the Blitz and I'm not
trying to ask the tough question I'm
just curious what is the psychological
take away of how to avoid how to avoid
tilt basically in this type of match you
don't you don't realize it until right
and by then it's already too late so
this is issue right yeah I lost three
games in a row at some point but yeah I
guess I just so comfortable with the
lead that I had and I just thought I
would do better or the two plus one but
somehow I once the DBS is the first ever
three one segment you've ever lost you
lost to Magnus you lost to akaru but
you've won the three one segment against
Magnus you drew versus a karo and this
is the first time you've ever lost a 3-1
segment so in a way it's kind of like
Maxime won the match yeah well I have a
question for both you I mean when it was
such a big lead it went all the way up
to seven points and Maxime what kind of
ballpark did you want to get it back to
to think you have a chance
in the bullet and Wesley you said that
you've got a bit distracted because of
the lead and maybe you lost a threat a
bit but what kind of lead were you
trying to keep for yourself heading into
the boat where Maxime was the perceived
favorite I was hoping to score safety
percent or 45% on the reverse one
section but again vaccine at the point I
mean the match is long so the most
important thing is to play well and it
was played as I was you know I was
losing energy on the middle of the match
and yeah and my side of course ideally I
would have been on 50% combo before that
section but yeah once I was done by
seven I mean any any sort of reducing of
the margin was fine by me so the - 3 - 4
- -5 I mean of course with - 5 it's very
difficult to two months have come back
in bullets but you know anything but but
- 7 basically yeah it's usually goes
around 10 11 games pretty much so so you
- do you it's actually fighters like
it's if it's a Maximus it's it's
definitely a match strategy we talked a
lot about because of the unique format
with time ticking away right so you know
you're trying to come back Maxime but
you also know there's a clock running
out because of that there were some
games that were really a close call
whether to resign whether to play it out
what was what was sort of your strategy
there you had one game you played out
really far trying to hold the draw
down a piece and ultimately that loss
hurt then there was the game you've
resigned very quickly when it looked
like Wesley was bringing the knight to
f3 and and maybe you could have held on
there if you had a move like c4 or
something and anyway I'm just curious
what your what your match strategy is to
like resign quickly versus play on when
you know you're trying to mount a
comeback now let's see when I did it was
I think it's a fortnight of three you
can play king h1 yeah maybe but you know
of course every our point is is critical
in this situation so you just you just
decide where whether you you're to last
world or you oh you you have a chance
and so you have to keep fighting on even
if that means within two minutes
especially you know you have to go by
your feelings yeah so is there like a
criteria would you rank like a
half-point worth like three minutes or
something like that are you thinking
like that at all or it's just a feel
like all right I need to give away this
game I shouldn't even try to play this
anymore if you have a chance for at
least three minutes because three
minutes is one game right oh okay yeah
make such I guess you just solve the
math I'm not good at math you know but
makes sense well winning it as my
picture winning position bullet to do
not make any any accidents that's the
simplest way I think in the second
bullet game I was probably lost or at
the bad position but I think I won the
first two bullets isn't a ghost you know
you can correct yeah yeah like I don't
remember either the first game I don't
got the lead
I don't think the lead ever shrunk to
one game right it was always to do oh it
did that's right you won the first two
bullet game Wow get along J apparently
and it was obviously very close and we
were all on the edge of our seat and and
yeah I mean it was it was very difficult
for for both you guys but let's see last
question for me anyway is our daily
question today was asking about time
zones and how difficult it can be to
play late obviously we you know you're
in India right now it's it's what for
you to a.m. 2:30 I know you're like me
you like to go to bed around 9:00 p.m.
with a nice cup of more milk and a good
book that's me and you right so how is
it how is it for you staying up way past
your bedtime playing this late and do
you feel like it affected anything in a
bit more than the day so that I can't
complain you know I mean the good thing
about speeches the guilty can play
online and you can play anywhere in the
world and your opponent can also play
anywhere in the world
so yeah it's amazing how technology is
advanced compared to ten years ago yeah
I heard also think they were started to
play 1 a.m. earlier today it was 1:00
a.m. in China when the math is much
larger so it can get really complain but
but yeah I mean I was talking in the in
the final half of the match for changed
somehow well we hope you get some rest
before the grand Chester wrap and
bullets begins there in Kolkata
congratulations again Maxime last
question for you predictions right now
have you winning tomorrow's match by
about thirty three and a half to 1/2
according to chat because you're gonna
lose what you're gonna draw one game to
me via Mouse slit what would you say to
that oh if you win 33 and a half to have
it's not like a triple adoption what
happens in that case yeah like don't you
like take me out for like pizza and a
movie like a dad date is you dot if you
adopt me how much video game time do I
get allotted like as my dad how much
video game time do I get all right
Wesley
I know you want to get it on this action
and try to adopt me so just hook up with
Nick and get on the schedule we got
super geum's lining up to try to adopt
today me so the way to work is we're
gonna have three disciplines the major
speech has championship disciplines but
I think we won't have increment it'll be
five three and one the way it works is
you're competing against a countdown
timer to try to adopt me but no adoption
can end if time runs out so if Maxime
has won like six games and time runs out
I still have to draw or win to stop the
to stop the adoption so that's kind of
how it works it'll be a three-hour match
I think that I think viewers can donate
to go toward both Maxime for his efforts
and and maybe some sort of charity we're
pulling that together I don't get
anything for being there besides
publicly humiliated so that's story of
my life I don't even I don't even get
any money for doing it but you know
it'll be fun
don't make it sound easy don't make it
sound like it's easy I you know alright
hey you guys have been great
Maxime we'll see you tomorrow morning
Wesley good luck in Kolkata and
always late Gregory and in hopper cannot
see you Amy sir my guys did yeah hey
those guys are awesome they're so nice
you know Danny we forgot to ask one
important question that say what's that
well there's a now that was he shows on
to these semies we'd ask him what he
made of his chances against Gladys love
words India oh that's true well well
well as Maxime tomorrow while he's
playing me what he thinks who he thinks
is the favorite it's it's pretty late
for him but no they really are great
guys and Wesley so wishing Maxine the
best of luck in the in the in the
candidates which likely it looks like
Maxine will make it so that's amazing
and and Maxine wishing him the best of
luck in the Grantchester
final rappin in blitz leg before before
the London Championship the London
finals so there you go we've got Wesley
so facing off against Vladislav Artemyev
it's amazing to think that our Tim
you've may really be the favorite in
that match I know he's the new name on
the block the new kid but that guy has
been so impressive I don't know I mean
to me I look at Wesley so is the favor
who do you think I love how you just
juggle that answer and was you came up
with the solution I don't know so let's
make Robert do it yeah yeah and I'm not
certain because our Timmy have got off
to a very bad start against Levon
Aronian but he proved just like Maxime
did that he can mount a comeback and I
do think that Wesley is currently the
stronger of the two players in classical
chess and I don't think that our tim is
beef to read bishop be two systems will
kind of do him justice against Wesley so
so I'm saying Wesley's the favorite I
think that our Timmy O's probably I give
him around 40% or so but he's hard to
gauge thus far as he's dominated by the
final swarm is two matchups but Wesley
so is just a monster at these SEC
matches well we got one more batch up
still that'll be on December 4th but
right after this show let's remind you
as soon as Robert and I sign off the
ladies take over Maria and rule Innova
on a Rudolph Alexander butch as and
Jennifer Shehadeh femme fatale we've
already had thousands donate
and more to come I'm sure these ladies
battle and team chefs for charity it's
gonna be a blasting big blast erson I
got um I got some pizza to get from my
producer here who's worked super hard I
got some private discussion with Robert
then I want to talk about on-air let's
just say it may or may not involve the
beard but snow Shave November Danny you
cannot possibly criticize me during this
month
nobody even does that anymore no I'm
kidding I do do a lot of things you're
criticizing me cuz I don't have a beard
I'm criticizing you for criticizing me
when no ship November is to raise
awareness and money for cancer that's
Evan from cancer exactly so and it is a
great cause I donate I support and I
support the beard so I want snot but
it's the month of November yep so way to
rub it in Shave November make your
donations i will i will donate but
though i will not have a beard but thank
you to everyone who's tuned in tomorrow
we've got more action stick around for
femme fatale and next time robin and i
have the call on a speech chess champion
will be December and we'll see you then